Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zum Chaos Radio 215, live aus dem CCCB in der Marienstraße 11, wo ihr auch gerne noch vorbeikommen könnt. Und der Rest kann mal kurz sagen, dass er hier ist. Hallo.
Hallo.
Das ist ein bisschen steigerungsfähig. Und ansonsten, wir reden heute über das Chaos Communication Camp 2005. Ich glaube, im CCCB hat es die letzten zehn, natürlich und ich glaube, im gesamten CCCB hat es irgendwie das letzte halbe Jahr kein anderes Thema mehr gegeben. Und das wollen wir dann auch gebührlich feiern. Und dazu haben wir uns eingeladen, beziehungsweise stehen in Verfügung der Starbark, der Tim und die Ariane und Jintonic und jede Menge Jintonic. Es sprach zu ihnen, der Jintonic. Ja, dann würde ich doch als allererstes mal so ein bisschen die Frage an euch richten. Was habt ihr so mit dem Camp zu tun? Starbark?
Mit dem jetzigen oder mit dem Camp allgemein?
Das darfst du gerne ausführlich beantworten.
Also auf jeden Fall, ich war tatsächlich bei allen deutschen Camps dabei, also seit dem 99er und war die ersten zwei im NOC tätig, also im Network Corporation Center. Hab beim dritten, nee, dritten und vierten, nee dritten auch noch NOC, beim vierten so ein bisschen PL und diesmal auch wieder so NOC und ein bisschen PL gemacht.
Okay, PL, kannst du uns nochmal erklären?
Weißt du doch, Tim, die Produktionsleitung.
Und was produziert die Produktionsleitung? Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
PL ist die Projektleitung, das ist was ganz anderes. Du warst definitiv nicht in der Produktionsleitung. Das stimmt.
Moment, aber ihr seid hier die super Stichwortgeber. Jetzt musst du das leider auseinander dividieren.
Tim, nicht trinken, erklären. Ja, das ist der Running Gag seit dem ersten Camp, dass es eine Projektleitung und eine Produktionsleitung gibt. Das ist schon mal als hausinterner Fnord geplant gewesen. Hat als solcher auch, glaube ich, ganz gut funktioniert. Hat eine Weile gedauert, bis das alle unterbekommen hat.
Du magst uns das jetzt auch erklären.
Kann ich machen. Bitte. Die Projektleitung kümmert sich um das Projekt und die Produktionsleitung kümmert sich, wie der Name schon nahelegt, um die Produktion. Es gab tatsächlich auch dieses Jahr wieder ganz viele, die das durcheinander gebracht haben. Ich fand eine ziemlich gute Erklärung, dass sich die Produktionsleitung so mit der Hardware beschäftigt und die Projektleitung mit den Menschen dahinter. Wobei Hardware ein wenig... Also Hardware, Essen, Toiletten, Duschen, alles, was auf dem Platz rumsteht.
Das sind diejenigen, die dafür sorgen, dass wir eine Infrastruktur haben, die sonst zum Beispiel ein Konferenzgebäude zur Verfügung stellen würde. Also eine gewisse Infrastruktur, mit der man dann arbeiten kann.
Also das Camp ist ja im Prinzip ein Campingplatz. Aber wir machen das ja an einer Stelle, wo es eigentlich keinen Campingplatz gibt. Also muss ein Campingplatz überhaupt erst mal gebaut werden. Und das macht die Produktion.
Das heißt, die Produktion ist ein großer Campingplatzbetreiber.
Kann man so sagen. Campingplatzbauer.
Wo du gerade dran bist. Du machst das Ganze auch schon ein bisschen länger. Ja. Dann erzähl uns doch mal, wie das bei dir angefangen hat.
Bei mir hat das angefangen, indem ich das erste Mal in Holland an dem ersten Hacker-Camp teilgenommen habe. Das war anno 1993. Hacking at the end of the universe. Was eine etwas überzogene Formulierung ist für Campingplatz. Und halt so ein richtiger Campingplatz. Also Holland, Campingplatz.
Und Holland ist jetzt nicht unbedingt the end of the universe.
Naja, es war halt ein Witz. Aber es war halt so ein ganz normaler Campingplatz. Wo, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch die allermeisten Teilnehmer nicht gecampt haben. Also das hat zwar auf dem Campingplatz stattgefunden. Es gab auch einige Zelte. Aber ich glaube, die große Mehrheit der Teilnehmer kam da hin. Also tagsüber und weiß nicht, wann die so gegangen sind. Ich meine, mich zu erinnern, dass da auch schon knapp 1000 Leute waren. Aber die Zeltanzahl war sicherlich eher so im zweistelligen Bereich.
Das heißt, das hat wahrscheinlich dort stattgefunden, wo es nicht allzu weit von der Stadt oder von einem etwas größeren Ort weg war.
Nein, Holland ist ja nix ganz weit weg von der Stadt. Von daher haben sie alle Camper. Genau.
Und das heißt, es ist irgendwie ein strategisches Erstreben, jetzt Campsites zu suchen, die möglichst weit von der Zivilisation entfernt liegen und trotzdem noch irgendwie machbar sind oder ist das eher ein Zufall.
Du meinst jetzt für den Club?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Ja, naja, also ich denke am Anfang war es zumindest sehr wünschenswert, einen Ort zu haben, wo man wirklich das Gefühl haben kann, man wäre relativ weit weg von der Zivilisation. Auch wenn man eigentlich gar nicht so weit weg ist von der Zivilisation.
Und wie ging das dann weiter nach dem Holland-Camp? Habt ihr gedacht, geil, das machen wir jetzt auch?
Ja, nee, nach diesem ersten Holland-Camp hatte ich noch nicht so den Eindruck, dass das irgendjemand auch machen wollte. Dann haben es die Holländer noch mal gemacht, nämlich vier Jahre später, 1997. Das war dann die HIP, Hacking in Progress. Das war auf einem Campingplatz, auf einem anderen Campingplatz diesmal. Und das war dann schon deutlich größer. Also haben sehr viel mehr Leute mit Zelten teilgenommen. Also gefühlt so die große Mehrheit aller Teilnehmer war dann auch sozusagen wirklich am Campen. Und das hatte auch noch mal so einen ganz anderen Groove. Und daraus entstand dann eben die Idee, das dann mal so im CCC-Style zu machen.
Und das habt ihr dann in die Hand genommen?
Genau, dann kam irgendwie 1999 Anfang des Jahres der Beschluss, dass man mal so einen Camp auch mal probieren sollte. Und das fand dann eben auch statt in Altlandsberg seinerzeit, auch in der Nähe von Berlin auf so einer Pferdewiese. Das war dann im Prinzip das erste Mal, dass das so aus der CCC-Community heraus entstand.
Was hattet ihr denn damals so für Infrastruktur? Oder für Bedingungen?
Na ja, also ich meine, das ist ja klar, was man braucht. Man braucht Strom, Wasser und Internet. Diese moderne Trinität des Überlebens.
Und von welcher Art von Internet sprechen wir da?
Na, wir hatten damals die Telekom überredet, da so einen Funkmast hinzustellen. Und jetzt frag mich mal, was ich überhaupt finde. Weißt du das noch, was wir da hatten? Also die Holländer hatten sechs, wir hatten mehr. 50? Ja, ich glaube so war es in der Großen Ordnung.
Also ihr seid schon mit vergleichbar amtlichen Zahlen an Start gekommen?
Ja, das war 99. Also da war halt noch nicht mit wir legen irgendwie Glasfaser irgendwo hin. Da gab es irgendwie in Deutschland auch nicht mal Glasfaser auf der Straße und neben der Schiene, sondern das war halt wirklich bis zum nächsten Knotenpunkt musste da halt Richtfunk gemacht werden.
Ja, das ist ja aber durchaus ernst gemeint. Also 50 Megabit für die Zeit ist ja durchaus...
Absolut, das war total herausragend und bahnbrechend und alle waren total stolz, dass das Ding sowohl funktioniert hat, als auch nicht umgefallen ist, wie manche befürchtet haben. Nach dem Aufhängen der Fahne, genau. Und ansonsten gab es halt Wasser- und Stromgeneratoren, das übliche Spiel, was wir jetzt im Prinzip dieses Jahr auch wieder gemacht haben, nur halt noch in einer etwas anderen Dimension. Ich glaube, beim ersten Camp waren wir so 1200 Leute auf dem Acker, weil das war ja dann auch erstmal noch eine neue Sache. Ja, und dann sind wir ja in unseren 4-Jahres-Wiederholungsmodus reingegangen, weil sich das eben schön abwechselte mit dem 4-Jahre-Wiederholungsmodus in Holland, die ja seitdem auch immer weiter Camps gemacht haben. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt 5 und die haben jetzt schon 6 gemacht.
Und von diesem ersten Camp, wie ging... Also ihr seid euch sofort einig gewesen, das machen wir nochmal.
Ja, ich denke, keine Ahnung, wie hast du das so gesehen? Du musst das erzählen. Eine Veranstaltung ist ja immer dann erfolgreich, wenn am Ende der Veranstaltung alle vom nächsten Mal reden.
Und das war dann der Fall?
Das war definitiv der Fall. Also das kam, glaube ich, schon ganz gut an.
Na, das ist doch klasse. Du musst aber noch Ariane fragen, was ihr eigentlich gefolgt habt. Genau, deswegen, ich habe jetzt die dritte im Bunde komplett ignoriert, weil wir so eingestiegen sind.
Ja, das ist okay, weil die Fragen sind nicht abgesprochen. Also ich muss jetzt improvisieren.
So, dann erzähl doch mal kurz was über dich und was du mit dem Camp zu tun hast.
Ja, gute Frage. Ich habe mich eigentlich komplett rausgehalten aus der letzten Orga. War 2011 mal kurz beim Aufbau da. Das war das erste Mal, dass ich überhaupt auf einem Hacker-Event war. Da habe ich dann kurz geguckt, habe bestaunt, dass man da mit irgendwelchen, wie heißen diese Teile? Flüge über den Acker fuhr. Was macht man da? Wir legen da Kabel.
Du meinst der Flug, der dreimal abgebrochen ist?
Genau, der Flug. Dann habe ich gedacht, okay, das ist ganz schön krass, ich fahre jetzt mal wieder. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, Camp dieses Jahr, mache ich irgendwas. Ich habe vorher keine große Zeit, halte mich da auch komplett raus. Das sind immer diese ganzen komischen Pets und Wikis und you name it, fraps, all diese Sachen. Ich habe keinen Plan. Ich musste immer erst mal da stehen und erst mal überlegen, wie mein Passport ist. Keine Ahnung. Von so gesehen war ich dann einfach nur bei den letzten paar Meetings. Dann habe ich gesagt, ich habe keinen Plan, ich kann nur nichts, aber ich bin da. Und so war das dann auch.
Und du hast dann effektiv was getan?
Also effektiv, kann ich sagen, habe ich gewartet.
Und irgendwie hat es dich dann ins BR verschlagen, oder?
Genau, und dann habe ich dort gewartet und habe dann auch mal gesagt, der kommt gleich wieder, das muss da hin und warte, das liegt dort und dort.
Du hast schon sinnvoll Dinge getan, du hast Leute betrunken gemacht.
Ja, das auch, das kann ich ganz gut.
Das ist wichtige Skills, gerade beim Camp. Genau, was das Camp anbetrifft und das BR im Speziellen, das machen wir gleich noch. Die ersten Camps, das erste Camp, wo ich dabei war, hat stattgefunden in Finofort. Dann ist uns Finofort ein bisschen zu klein geworden. Bist du das korrekt?
Das trifft die Sache, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Genau, und dann seid ihr auf die Suche nach einer neuen Location gekommen und seid nach Mildenberg gekommen. Genau, dort war aber irgendwie gar nichts mit Infrastruktur. Das heißt, da musste relativ viel rangekarrt werden.
Da muss immer viel rangekarrt werden. Es muss immer viel rangekarrt werden, weil du hast halt einfach nicht Campingplatz. Erstmal hast du keine Glasfaser im Boden. Dann hast du auch in der Regel keine Wasserinfrastruktur, die jetzt also Frischwasser oder Trinkwasser an wichtige und weniger neuralgische Punkte bringt, die Leute einfach was zum Waschen haben. Dann hast du die ganze Sanitärinfrastruktur, die muss natürlich aufgeblasen werden, wenn du da so eine Kleinstadt für eine Woche hin verpflanzt. Und vielleicht das Internet. Das Internet, das ist schon ein nicht zu unterschätzender Aufwand, der da getrieben werden muss. Und da gibt es eigentlich kaum Orte, die jetzt Open Air sind und halbwegs nach Natur aussehen, die das so mit sich bringen. Aber Mildenberg hat eine ganze Menge Infrastruktur gehabt. Sie hatte sich nur leider nicht unbedingt so in den Kapazitäten, wie wir sie gebraucht haben.
Das heißt, wir konnten schon aus den bestehenden Kapazitäten schöpfen, haben da aber noch ein bisschen was draufsetzen müssen.
Ja, also ich meine zum Beispiel in Alt Landsberg hatten wir noch nicht mal Abwasser. Also da gab es keine funktionierende Abwasserleitung vom Feld weg, die wir hätten benutzen können, sondern wir mussten sozusagen die ganze Scheiße im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes mit Tankwagen weg transportieren lassen. Das war teuer und aufwendig und naja Dixie Realität halt. Das ist halt auch nicht so geil. Da war man dieses Jahr deutlich besser aufgestellt.
Das heißt, dieses Jahr hatten wir also richtige Container mit Duschen und mit Toiletten, die dann in ein etwas komplexeres Abwassersystem geführt wurden. Und da habe ich jetzt schon Geschichten gehört darüber, die Sache mit den vier Wasserleitungen bzw. Abwasserleitungen. Es gab, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, mit den vier Wasserarten, nämlich Frischwasser, Brauchwasser, Grauwasser und Schwarzwasser.
Genau, das waren jetzt fünf, aber ich glaube, ich muss auch zugeben, ich stecke nicht zu sehr in den Details der Wasserplanung, aber ich glaube, Brauchwasser und Frischwasser sind in dem Moment dasselbe. Das heißt, bei Trinkwasser und Frischwasser handelt es sich um die Wasserzuführung. Das eine kommt aus dem Trinkwassernetz und das andere kommt aus dem Wald. Ich gucke mal so hinten in die Ecke und erwarte einen Nicken oder so, aber ich glaube, ich kann keins erwarten. Grau- und Schwarzwasser waren die Kodierungen für die Art und Weise, also für das Abwasser, was da jeweils so drin ist.
Also Schwarzwasser ist nicht unbedingt die Farbe, die es hat, aber man kommt ungefähr hin, wenn man sich etwas denkt.
Genau, also Grauwasser ist das, was aus den Duschen kommt.
Genau, also nicht unbedingt auch zum Konsum empfohlen, aber möglicherweise anders.
Das Kernproblem, man kann das ja schnell zusammenfassen, ist, dass einfach die Abwasserleitung, es gab zwar eine Abwasserleitung, aber die hatte halt mitnichten die Kapazität, die man jetzt gebraucht hätte. Also man kann da einfach nicht so viel durchjagen, wie von 5000 Leuten da einfach in einer Woche die ganze Zeit produziert wird. Und deswegen musste das gebuffert werden.
Und haben wir das dann effektiv auch abholen lassen, oder haben wir das einfach über die Zeit verteilt?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie es ausgegangen ist. Die Kernidee bei diesem Gebuffer ist ja, dass das in Säcken zwischengespeichert wird. Und dann eben zu Zeiten, wo die Nutzung nicht ganz so ausführlich ist, dass das dann so langsam abgeführt wird. Und ich weiß, dass es den Notfallplan gab, dass wenn das auch nicht reicht, dass das dann mit Tankwagen abgeholt wird. Ich glaube, es war sowohl als auch. Ich glaube, es war eine Mischung aus beiden.
Und ansonsten hat der Park ja auch eine ganz spannende Infrastruktur gehabt. Es gab, also das Ganze muss man dazu sagen, ist ein Industriemuseum. Da wurden früher Ziegel gebrannt in diesem Ziegelei-Park. Und das ist nicht zu ganz unwissentlichen Teilen nach Berlin gegangen. Eigentlich fast ausschließlich, soweit ich weiß. Und das Spannende war, diese Infrastruktur ist ja auch ganz gut bespielt worden. Also da wurde sehr viel beleuchtet. Da gab es Parkeisenbahnen, die eigentlich wohl mal auch Ziegelsteine oder zumindest den Ton oder Leben dafür zugeliefert haben, die heute Gäste durch die Gegend fahren. Auch die sind ein bisschen gepimpt worden. Wie ist das bei euch so angekommen? Also wer ist mit dieser Bahn gefahren von euch? Und wer ist dafür verantwortlich?
Peter, hier geht gerade die Kopfhörersignale in die Knie.
Nö, ich bin nicht beim Bahnfahren, sondern im Speziellen halt auch diese ganze Beleuchtung. Die muss ja irgendwie zustande kommen.
Ja, also überhaupt, man muss erstmal diese ganze Geschichte da zustande kommen. Das müsste man vielleicht auch mal erläutern, wie das ist. Also auch gerade diese Unterscheidung mit Projektleitung und Produktionsleitung, das ist ja jetzt nicht nur so...
Das wolltest du uns ja eben nicht erklären, was das auseinander ist.
Doch, klar, aber du kannst ja ruhig mal nachhaken. Du kannst das ja mal ruhig aus der Nase ziehen. Also, ganz einfach. Und das Konzept gibt es halt von Anfang an. Man muss halt überhaupt erstmal die Infrastruktur aufbauen. Das bedeutet, man muss sie planen, man muss sie besorgen, stellen, hinfahren oder hinfahren lassen, zeitlich koordinieren, das alles aufzubauen. Und man kann auch nicht alles vorher einfach fertig bestellen und dann lädt man das vom Lastwagen ab und dann funktioniert es. Sondern es muss ja auch vor Ort gebaut werden. Es muss zusammengesteckt, gezimmert, aufgebaut werden. Ich glaube, am Anfang haben wir uns auch noch um den Zeltaufbau weitgehend selber gekümmert. Dann kommt natürlich das Chaos noch dazu, dass es gar nicht so läuft, wie man sich das geplant hat. Und dann muss man halt eh nochmal irgendwie alles umschmeißen. Genau, und wir haben uns halt von Anfang an die Hilfe der Pionen geholt. Das ist eine etablierte Partytruppe, Partieorganisationstruppe in Berlin. Vor allem bekannt als Markus und André, die halt da das Zepter von Anfang an geschwungen haben, die hervorragende Open Air Parties gemacht haben und die einfach extrem viel Erfahrung schon damals hatten mit so einen Aufbauten. Also die einfach gewohnt sind, so einen 24-Stunden-Betrieb von so einer fragilen, sozial prekären Gesamtsituation zu haben. Vor allem in ähnlicher Größenordnung. Also das heißt, sie wissen irgendwie, wie viel Dixies da hin müssen, wie viel Duschen man braucht. Wobei es natürlich immer noch unterschiedlich ist, ob es jetzt Partypublikum oder Nerd sind, aber irgendwie zumindest sie wissen irgendwie, wo man Strom herkriegt, wo man Bauzüge herkriegt. Und auch so Sachen, an die wir niemals im Traum auch nur gedacht hätten. Also allein sowas wie eine Werkstatt haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das das erste ist, was dir so in den Sinn kommen würde.
Es war das erste, als ich aufs Camp gekommen bin, wo ich mir in den Kopf gefasst habe und gesagt habe, natürlich, natürlich, weil auf einmal waren diese ganzen zurechtgesägten Holzbretter da, die dort ausgelegt wurden, wo sie total Sinn machen, wo es aber im Normalbetrieb niemals irgendwelche Bretter geben würde.
Genau, also die Brücken über die Schienen, auch größere Brücken über längere Schienenbereiche, überhaupt diese ganzen Installationen, Ständer für Lampenzeug, wie kriegst du den Kram einfach installiert. Da brauchst du einfach Material, da brauchst du Leute, die Plan haben von Material, die auch schon vorher wissen, was man so für ein Material vielleicht auch vor Ort gebrauchen könnte. Du kannst das ja nicht bis in das letzte Element vorplanen und vorbauen, sondern du musst es halt da haben. Du musst Leute haben, die im richtigen Moment auf die richtige Stelle im Lager zeigen können, sagen, ja hier, nimm da mal irgendwie die Dachlatten mit und Nägelgips da hinten und Hammer haben wir auch. Und die haben wir auch in den ausreichenden Mengen, dass auch mehrere Gruppen parallel arbeiten können und nicht die ganze Zeit rumrennen mit, ich hab keinen Hammer, ich kann nichts machen, ja warte mal bis die anderen in zwei Stunden fertig sind. So funktioniert das nicht, weil du natürlich eine Myriade an Abhängigkeiten im Prinzip hast. Und wenn du die halt von vornherein zu klein dimensionierst, oder dir überhaupt dieser Problematik nicht bewusst bist, dann fährst du einfach so eine Veranstaltung total kaputt. Dann funktioniert einfach gar nichts, du kriegst deine Zeitpläne nicht eingehalten, du kriegst auch vielleicht deine Sicherheitsanforderungen nicht eingehalten.
Du musst dann auch erstmal zur Behörderin und dir gewisse Dinge genehmigen lassen.
Ja, das ist auch noch so ein Teil, das fängt ja dann auch schon mit sowas an, wie mit der unteren oder oberen Naturschutzbehörde reden, über die Belastung, die die Veranstaltung so hat. Da gehört auch wieder diese Wasser-Abwasser-Problematik dazu, aber auch so Sachen wie Lärmbelästigung oder wenn du halt jetzt ein See mitnutzen willst, in welcher Klasse, in welcher Kategorie wird dieser See geführt? Ist das Naturschutzgebiet, Landschaftsschutzgebiet? Was sind da die Auflagen? Das muss alles im Vorfeld ausgehandelt werden. Das sind einfach so Sachen, an die wir als Computer Club natürlich früher nie, auch nur im Traum, gedacht hätten. Oder halt auch so ganz praktische Sachen wie Parkplatzordnung. Also, dass du überhaupt einen Plan hast, wie du deine Parkplätze einteilst, wie du sie planst, dass die Zufahrtswege freigehalten werden, dass du auch Personal hast, was nicht überarbeitet ist, dass es einen ganz klaren Schichtenplan gibt. All diese ganzen Sachen. Das ist ein Riesending. Und das ist das, was die Produktion gemacht hat. Und das war schon damals immer diese Zweiteilung. Pion mit ihren Teams haben die Produktion gemacht. Die haben sozusagen den Campingplatz auf den Acker gestellt, wobei ihnen das auch noch die komplette Gestaltung beinhaltet. Und Gestaltung heißt jetzt nicht nur Licht, sondern auch diesen Blick für Räume haben. Wo macht man Wege hin? Wo macht man Kreuzungen hin? Wo schafft man Sichtachsen? Wo passt irgendetwas hin, wo passt irgendwas nicht hin? Und dann natürlich auch, welche Dynamik entwickelt so eine Veranstaltung? Wo ziehen die Menschenströme hin? Essen, Getränke, Angebote, wo steht das Wasser, wo stehen die Klos? Daraus entstehen halt auch Strömungen. Dementsprechend musst du dann auch diese Wege schaffen. Dann musst du gucken, wie kriegt man diese Wege sicher, dass auch wenn die noch verpeilt nachts um drei, wenn das Licht ausgefallen ist, da lang tapern, dass halt kein Drama passiert. Natürlich auch Fluchtwege, also wo man irgendwie Krankenwagen, Feuerwehr im Zweifel durchfahren. Genau, Müll, auch so ein Thema, was man überhaupt nicht auf dem Zeiger hat. Da haben wir Gott sei Dank in unserer Community verhältnismäßig wenig Probleme, wenn man das jetzt nochmal mit...
Kommerziellen Festivals zum Beispiel.
Ja, Partys an sich. Wo erst natürlich der Truffi-Faktor nochmal auf einem ganz anderen Level ist, aber wo auch, sagen wir mal, die Bereitschaft, sich mülltechnisch etwas zurückzuhalten, eher eingeschränkt ist. Bei uns ist das, glaube ich, diesmal wieder relativ gut gelaufen, weil wir einfach auch diesen Vorteil haben, wenn wir halt eine Regel durchsetzen wollen, dann ist schon mal sehr viel damit erreicht, indem du ein Schild ausdruckst und irgendwo hinhängst.
Eigentlich unintuitiv bei etwas, was sich Chaos Computer Club nennt, aber es funktioniert tatsächlich erstaunlich gut.
Ja, es sind doch alles so kleine Programme, die da rumlaufen, und dann so, oh, eine Instruktion, die ausgeführt werden muss. Hurra! Das klingt putzig, aber es funktioniert super. Also das ist auch immer interessant, wenn man so Leute, die da hinkommen, die eigentlich eher die Partys gewohnt sind, gerade so die Essensstände, wenn man die halt so fragt zu dem Sozialverhalten der Nerds, da sind die eigentlich immer ziemlich begeistert, weil die auf Ansagen reagieren und Dinge richtig machen, wenn es nötig ist.
Also ich hab dann am letzten Tag stand das Pfand, neben den verlassenen und abgebauten Zelten, Sorten rein im Kasten, daneben ein Beutel mit PET-Flaschen und daneben dann noch ein Beutel mit Müll. Also wirklich phänomenal.
Ich hab das auch gesehen, da hatten irgendwelche Leute, die die gute Intention, leere Flaschen so zu markieren, indem sie sie verkehrt rum in den Kasten getan haben. Und dann wurde ihnen gesagt, das ist zwar im Prinzip eine ganz tolle Idee, aber unsere Engel müssen die alle wieder rumdrehen und dann wurden die auch direkt kestenweise korrekt wieder einsortiert. Also das ist tatsächlich enorm, wie hilfreich da die Teilnehmer sind.
Also allgemein so, die Ordnung ist halt, also gerade so dieses Müllvermeidung oder auch Müllbeseitigung, also wer irgendwie auf Festivals war, ist als Vergleich, also die Fusion zum Beispiel oder wie sei es Wacken. Also es gab nach dem Camp so ein schönes Bild von irgendwie so ein Vergleichsbild Wacken und... Nee, das war Sonne, Mond und Sterne, war dieses Volkatastrophe. Genau, also irgendwie so abgerissene Sofas und irgendwie eingestürzte Zelte und Pavillons und irgendwie unten war so eine saubere Wiese und so ein Datenklo stand in der Mitte. Wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher bin, dass das Foto wirklich von nach dem Camp war. Ich glaube, das war vor dem Camp. Es sah tatsächlich zwei Tage später so aus. Die Caravan-Ära war das? Ah, da hinten. Okay, das ist auch schon ein bisschen fies, aber es sah ja an sich gut aus. Der Rasen war natürlich ausgetreten etc. Welcher Rasen?
Da war kein Rasen mehr.
Also man hätte auch einen etwas treffenderen Bereich auswählen können, aber ich glaube der Unterschied wäre immer noch deutlich zu erkennen gewesen. Also das ist sozusagen das, was wir so ein bisschen gelernt haben. Aber selbstverständlich ist der Club sehr viel besser im Errichten seiner im spezifischen Infrastruktur. Und das ist eben das, was dann unter anderem die Projektleitung vor allem im Blick hat. Also natürlich die Zusammenarbeit mit der Produktion. Der Blick von oben. Und natürlich dann auch das Steuern der ganzen Camp-spezifischen, also Chaos Communication Camp spezifischen Infrastrukturen, die man eben jetzt auf Open Air Veranstaltungen so normalerweise eben nicht hat. WLAN, Netzwerk und dieser ganze andere Wahnsinn, der sich da so entpuppt.
Das heißt, wir haben da auch sehr viel, gerade was das Netzwerk angeht und so weiter und so fort, das ist letztendlich auch das, was wir beim Kongress so auffahren und mitunter dieselben Leute. Ist dabei du was im Nock auch dieses Mal wieder?
Zumindest bis zum Beginn der Veranstaltung.
Das ist ein gutes Stichwort. Die meisten kommen wahrscheinlich am offiziellen Tag 1 oder vielleicht auch am Tag 0 an, aber so ein Camp beginnt ja deutlich früher. Wann sind die ersten da tatsächlich auf dem Acker?
Also ich glaube tatsächlich so 2 Wochen vorher ist realistisch. Es war glaube ich der Freitag oder Samstag 1, 5 Wochen vorher. Also der Aufbau war ungefähr 10 Tage, wenn ich mich jetzt... Soweit ich weiß. Also Freitag sind irgendwie die ersten aufgeschlagen. oder 36.
Und abgesehen von den Pionen jetzt vom CCC aus, wer hat da zuerst im Wort-Sinn die Zelte aufgeschlagen? Also welche Infrastruktur wurde da zuerst errichtet?
Na ja, also die Struktur oder was aufgebaut wurde, hat ja irgendwie nicht wirklich was mit dem CCC zu tun. Also was natürlich zuerst aufgebaut wurde, ist natürlich das Backstage. Also man muss natürlich erstmal die Grundversorgung an Essen für die Helfer irgendwie sicherstellen. Du musst halt ein paar Duschen, ein paar Klos haben für alle Leute, die irgendwann kommen, die wollen natürlich sowas haben. Das heißt, das war irgendwie das Erste. Also Wasser ist vor allem das allerwichtigste. Strom, Wasser, Strom und Wasser, genau. Ein Generator, der schon mal Strom liefert, Essen und Entsorgung von Essen. Tatsächlich, das Internet kommt ein bisschen später, aber irgendwie so für den Aufbau war es tatsächlich erst mal das Backstage gemacht.
Soweit ich weiß, ist ja auch der Veranstaltungsfunk eines der ersten Sachen, die auch aufgebaut werden, oder?
Ja, Funkgeräte auf jeden Fall auch. Da muss man nicht wirklich viel aufbauen lassen. Die Geräte muss im Zweifel zwar ein Repeater irgendwann setzen, wenn das Feld größer wird, aber das geht dann erst los, wenn auch wirklich auf dem Platz angefangen wird, aufzubauen. Also wir fangen an, Creme für die Glasfasern zu ziehen, wir fangen an, die Zelte aufzubauen, wir fangen an, den Strom und das Wasser zu verlegen. Und ab dann brauchst du natürlich auch schon Funk.
Genau, und neben dem Veranstaltungsfunk haben natürlich auch sehr viele Leute das jährlich wieder verfügbare, oder in dem Fall vierjährig wieder verfügbare, Decknetz genutzt. Das hat das POG zur Verfügung gestellt. Und jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert. Denn wir haben hier fernmündlich den Sascha noch zugeschaltet. Ich weiß nicht, ob der uns hören kann. Sascha?
Also ich kann euch hören, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mich hören könnt.
Ah, hervorragend. So, guten Abend erst mal nach Bonn.
Ja, sehr schön, guten Abend zurück nach Berlin und an alle angeschlossenen Leute, die jetzt zuhören.
Sag mal, du gehörst zu den Leuten, die dann beim POG quasi die ganze Infrastruktur errichtet haben. Wann wart ihr denn da?
Also wir waren an dem Mittwoch, eine Woche vor Veranstaltungsbeginn, waren wir da und haben dann irgendwie angefangen, die Sachen aufzubauen.
Wie viel Infrastruktur könnt ihr euch verlassen? Ihr nutzt noch nicht die IP-Infrastruktur vom NOC, sondern ihr baut das komplett selber auf?
Genau, wir haben unsere eigenen Kabel auf dem Gelände. Wir ziehen meistens von Datenklo zu Datenklo, sofern die schon stehen, eigene Telefonleitungen, wo unsere Deckantennen dran kommen und wo dann auch die Telefone später angeschlossen werden. Also die Festtelefone, die zum Beispiel an der Kasse stehen oder im Pressezelt oder auch in den Sälen.
Und das ist ab welchem Tag?
Also das Decknetz ist relativ schnell verfügbar, sobald wir die Kabel ausgelegt haben. Also erst mal beziehen wir natürlich unser Zelt. Und dann werden wir alles aus dem Transporter im Zelt drin haben. Dann geht es halt los, dass wir die Kabel auslegen. Und meistens ist es dann so ein, zwei Tage, nachdem wir da ankommen, funktioniert dann Decknetz und man kann telefonieren auf dem Gelände.
Ja, euer Setup da ist ja schon ziemlich legendär. Also Starbuck hat es gerade schon angesprochen. Ihr seid da immer gut vorbereitet.
Also man muss dazu sagen, also sonst irgendwie war das Pocken irgendwie immer die ersten, die ihre Infrastruktur am Laufen hatten. Das war diesmal nicht so, diesmal war das noch schneller. Wirklich?
Die waren ja dann auch schon deutlich vorher da. Ja, das ist ja ein tolles Ausreden. Aber es war auch ganz gut, dass die schon so viel gemacht hatten, denn dann hatten wir auch schon eine Internetverbindung und konnten auch schon Gespräche nach draußen und von draußen anbieten.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, es war immer noch schnell genug. Wie viele Leute seid ihr, mit denen ihr das bestreitet?
Also die Grundgruppe oder der harte Kern, das waren mehr oder weniger zwei bis drei Leute. Das waren, sag ich deswegen, weil der Martin, der das auch 2001 mit mir angefangen und aufgebaut hat, jetzt leider nach dem Camp gesagt hat, Leute, das wird mir jetzt alles zu viel, ich hab da jetzt so keine Lust mehr drauf. Und damit ist uns schon doch ein recht großer Teil weggebrochen, für den wir jetzt auch noch händeringend irgendwie suchen. Also Ersatz suchen in irgendeiner Form, damit wir zum Beispiel den Kongress bestreiten können dieses Jahr.
Das heißt, du möchtest da gerade mal einen Aufruf starten, dann sag doch mal, wen ihr so braucht als Mitstreiter und was derjenige so mitbringen sollte und ja, welche Parameter sonst noch?
Oder diejenige.
Oder diejenige, na klar.
Ja, also das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig und auch relativ kurzfristig jetzt, wenn man bedenkt, dass was man da alles mitbringen muss für das, was Martin halt ersetzen soll. Also es wäre halt schön, wenn man schon mal irgendwie in dem Bereich Telefonanlagen unterwegs war und vielleicht schon mal eigenverantwortlich irgendwo eine Telefonanlage beim Kunden aufgebaut hat, in einem fremden Telefonnetz schon mal Sachen geschaltet hat. Das sind so die Sachen, die wir irgendwie brauchen. Also es gibt ja da im CCH ein festes Telefonnetz, an das wir angelassen werden dürfen. Das ist vom Haus die komplette Verkabelung. Und wir dürfen ja im CCH über die vorhandene Verkabelung zusätzlich zu dem bisher bestehenden Telefon vom Haus noch unsere ganzen Decktantennen und die festen Telefone schalten. Und da wär es schon echt super, wenn jemand irgendwie in dem Bereich schon mal gearbeitet hat und auch irgendwie eigenverantwortlich weiß, hier an die 40 Stellen müssen Antennen. Und jetzt versucht die mal da hinzukriegen. Das ist eine relativ große Aufgabe, die da jetzt so eine große Lücke, die da gefüllt werden muss. Aber wir versuchen natürlich alles, dass das irgendwie dann auf dem Kongress dieses Jahr auch klappt. Es wäre echt schade, wenn das dann durch sowas ins Wasser fallen würde.
Also wenn ihr noch irgendwie selber im Telefonanlagenbereich Kompetenz seid oder Leute kennen, die da Kompetenz haben und gerne mal bei so einer richtig großen Veranstaltung was machen würden, ich glaube da zieht ihr auch relativ, also das ist halt einfach beeindruckend, was das POG da überhaupt zustande bringt und auf den Camps überhaupt bei allen Veranstaltungen. Dann meldet euch bei Sascha, wie könnt ihr euch am besten erreichen?
Am einfachsten sascha.eventphone.de als E-Mail Adresse. Ansonsten gibt es auch auf der Webseite den ein oder anderen Hint, wo man uns irgendwie kontaktieren kann. Ich werde bestimmt wahrscheinlich auf dem Kongress auch dann irgendwie so einen kleinen Workshop anbieten. Das heißt, wenn man da mal reinschnuppern will für irgendwelche zukünftigen Veranstaltungen, dann wird das mit Sicherheit möglich sein. Aber ich denke oder ich befürchte, dass wenn wir keinen adäquaten Ersatz für den Martin finden, dass es dann echt wirklich viel, viel Arbeit wird an diesem Kongress. Und ich befürchte auch, dass wir es nicht komplett aufgebaut bekommen. Also die Leute, die da sich melden, das wäre toll, wenn ihr wirklich in dem Bereich schon mal was gemacht habt. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn ihr am 25.12. morgens um 8 oder 9 Uhr im CCH auf der Matte stehen könnt, um aufzubauen. Denn dann erwarten euch zwei Tage lang 40 Nektarantennen aufbauen.
Ja, das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen, wann ihr eigentlich so anfängt. Ich meine, es fehlt sowieso noch ein bisschen der POC-Talk. Den habt ihr noch nie gehalten, glaube ich, oder? Auf dem Kongress?
Ob ihr schon mal den POC-Talk gehalten habt?
Ich glaube, das kommt bei Ihnen. Es gab mal auf der Frostcon einen Vortrag. Es tut mir leid, dass ich den Tim nicht so gut verstehen kann. Das ist so ein bisschen raumklang. Ich glaube, das ist der Technik geschuldet, ist aber kein Problem. Wir hatten auf der Frostcon mal einen Talk gemacht, wie das POG so eigentlich funktioniert. Das war auch eigentlich für Veranstaltungen mal geplant, die auf dem Kongress stattfinden sollten, aber bisher ist nie dazugekommen.
Das heißt auch da mal gucken unter media.ccc.de und nach POG oder nach Eventphone suchen. Da sollte man dann entsprechend fündig werden. Gut, möchtest du noch was loswerden?
So auf die Schnelle aktuell nicht. Ich dachte, du hättest vielleicht noch die eine oder andere Frage zum Camp. Falls mich da noch jemand interessiert, wie das aussah.
Was sind eure Statistiken gewesen? Gab es irgendwelche Peaks im Vergleich zu anderen Kongressen? Wie viele Telefone gab es?
Das, was wir jedes Mal toppen, sind die Anzahl der Leute, die da sind und die tatsächlich ein Telefon mit haben. Das übertrifft jedes große Event, das vorhergehende.
Auch relativ gesehen zum Kongress?
Ja, wir hatten auf dem Camp dieses Mal das erste Mal auf diesen Camps deutlich mehr als auf dem letzten Kongress. Das hat mich persönlich sehr gewundert, weil der große Teil jetzt nicht bei den neuen Diensten, nenne ich sie jetzt mal, wie wir sie haben. Wir haben SIP und seit ein paar Events haben wir auch GSM mit dabei. Das macht das GSM-Team immer ganz super. Die sind bei uns mit angeschlossen. Man kann also seine SIM-Karte bzw. die SIM-Karte vom Kongress in sein Handy einlegen und ist damit auch erreichbar. Aber komischerweise waren es nicht diese neuen Dinge, sondern es war tatsächlich so, dass DECT über alle Maßen irgendwie die Zahlen gesprengt hat und deutlich mehr DECT-Telefone auf dem Camp waren, wie sie auf dem letzten Kongress waren.
Jetzt sag doch mal dir Zahl. Zahl sagen.
Zahl. Ich glaube, es waren irgendwie 2, 5 oder so was in der Größenordnung.
Ja, das ist schon super. Also da ist, aber ich kann, was das DECT angeht, es ist einfach, es funktioniert. Die Dinge haben Laufzeiten. Ich muss nicht mit einer SIM-Karte rumfummeln. Ich kann das schon gut nachvollziehen.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, umso länger wir mit dieser Anlage arbeiten, die wir da benutzen, umso mehr andere Sachen, die ich sehe und die wir auch durchtesten. Wir hatten jetzt auf dem Camp einen Test mit per SIP angebundenen Deckbasis-Stationen. Es ist leider alles nicht so wahnsinnig kompatibel und so offen, wie wir das jetzt mit der jetzigen Anlage haben. Umso mehr wir das POC machen mit dieser Anlage, umso mehr muss ich feststellen, dass das die einzige Wahl ist, um so was zu machen in der Größenordnung und um so viele verschiedene Telefone von verschiedenen Herstellern dran zu lassen. Also wir hatten auf dem letzten Kongress so eine handgemachte Grenze. Da haben wir damals mal, als wir die Anlage aufgesetzt haben, 2003 fürs erste Camp, wo wir da waren, haben wir gesagt, ja hier also 1000 Deck, das muss wohl reichen, das werden wir wohl nie schaffen. Ja und dann kam es halt so, dass wir das auf dem letzten Kongress erreichten und wir saßen erstmal da und sagten, oh, was denn jetzt? Wir können keine Decktelefone mehr einrichten. Das ist jetzt aber ein bisschen komisch. Und dann haben wir aber das Softwarelimit hochgedreht und jetzt haben wir bis 5.000 erstmal. Also 5.000 Decktelefone müsste für jeden sein.
Das werdet ihr nie springen.
Also bis zum nächsten Camp.
Okay, Sascha, dann danke ich dir erstmal bis hierhin. Und wir machen jetzt eine kurze Pause und danach schauen wir uns noch ein bisschen an, was es sonst noch so gab und was der Berliner Club hier so im Bear Village getrieben hat.
Ja.
Chaosradio 215 mit ganz schnell wieder zurückspurtenden Leuten, unter anderem mit Starbucks und mit Ariane. Und ohne Tim, der immer noch vor der Tür sitzt oder steht.
Wir können endlich sagen, was wir wollen. Endlich Redefreiheit.
Endlich Redefreiheit. Genau. Und wir waren stehen geblieben gerade bei der Infrastruktur und da im Speziellen beim POG und beim VOG. Jetzt ist es ja so, dass da durchaus noch noch eine ganz wichtige Komponente in Spiel kommt, die wir schon angesprochen haben, nämlich irgendwo muss der Strom herkommen. Und dieses Jahr hatten wir da externe Generatoren. Teilweise gab es da auch...
Also es gab minimal Feststrom von dem Gelände. Also da gab es ja ein paar Häuser, wo die Strom drin war, aber das hat natürlich bei weitem nicht für uns gereicht. Und dann haben wir halt noch diverse größere Aggregate dazu gemietet. Also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kann Sascha dazu noch was sagen, wenn er noch da ist.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht mehr in der Leitung. Ich kann ja noch mal versuchen, dazu zu nehmen.
Also das lustige ist ja, dass das pocken. Wir haben ja irgendwie anscheinend, die machen ein Telefon. Das läuft immer so easy, dass sie sich dann andere Sachen suchen. Und was sie sich letztes Camp gesucht haben, ist sich ein bisschen auf die Strommesstechnik auszudehnen. Das heißt, da haben sie sich an die ganzen Generatoren und Unterverteiler gehängt und haben geguckt, wie viel Strom da irgendwie auskommt, wie viel verbraucht wird. Und da wäre Sascha oder wahrscheinlich Martin auf jeden Fall auch ein guter Ansprechpartner gewesen.
Müssen wir jetzt selber machen, aber im Prinzip ist es ja auch schnell erklärt. Nämlich, zum einen gab es halt den Feststrom. Zum anderen hatten wir eine gewisse Anzahl von Generatoren. Und wir begrüßen an dieser Stelle auch wieder den Herrn Pridlove.
Guten Abend.
Und mit diesen Generatoren haben wir im Prinzip den Rest des Camps bestritten. Tim kann da glaube ich eine ganz besonders gute Story drüber erzählen. Denn ich glaube, mit diesen Generatoren hast du im Sendezentrum besonders viel Spaß.
Ich glaube, es gab da eine Planungsverspulung im Vorfeld. Man hätte sicherlich mit weniger Generatoren die Leistung bringen können, die Tasse, die auf dem Camp benötigt wurde. Es war aber nicht unklar, wo man überall Kabel ziehen konnte. Also ich glaube, das war eher ein Trade-off zwischen wie viel Kabel man legen muss und wie viele Generatoren man hinstellt. Und es war auch glaube ich nicht klar, ob man jetzt wirklich die Stromschienen unterquert bekommt. Und so stecke ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht so drin. Es war, sagen wir mal, einer der schwierigen Punkte, dass die Generatoren an Stellen standen, wo sie halt dann ihr Umfeld doch sehr beeinflusst haben. Gut, das weiß man dann danach besser. Das sind auch so Erfahrungswerte, die man eigentlich erst immer mit so einer Veranstaltung wirklich generiert bekommt. Danach ist man immer deutlich schlauer. Und das war auch jetzt bei den ersten beiden Camps nicht anders. Das erste Mal hat man eben die Herausforderung, so ein Gelände überhaupt erst mal urbar zu machen. Und man hat halt zahlreiche Annahmen, die dann eben zutreffen oder nicht zutreffen. Und am zweiten Mal kann man dann eigentlich aus dem vollen schöpfen. Also wenn man noch mal dahingehen würde, was jetzt so nicht gesetzt ist, dann könnte man natürlich ganz anders.
Planen. Und das heißt, das rammt so ein bisschen diese ganze Diskussion Infrastruktur ab. Dann, abgesehen von der Infrastruktur, es gab die beiden Vortragszelte. Das ist glaube ich auch das, was es schon immer irgendwie auf dem Camp gab. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt in der Größe. Das fasste jetzt irgendwie ein paar hundert Leute, diese Vortragszelte.
Also auf dem ersten Camp hatten wir ein großes Zelt, ein sehr großes Zelt, das hieß Hackcenter. Das war dann eben auch ein Vortragsort. War aber auch ein Ort, wo man eben zusammenkommen konnte. Das war auch so ein bisschen die Konsequenz aus dem, was wir eben kannten. Weil der Kongress hatte auch ein Hackcenter. Damals waren wir ja im Haus am Kölnischen Park. Hatte natürlich auch Vortragsräume. Man muss vielleicht ein bisschen aushunnen und dazu sagen, dass anders als der Kongress, der mehr oder weniger zur Wissensvermittlung auch hauptsächlich da ist. Das heißt, da haben wir nicht nur einen Vortragsraum, sondern vier Tracks und noch Workshopräume. Das Camp ist immer so ein bisschen eher das Meet and Greet. Das heißt, man kommt zusammen, man hat Spaß. Diese Wissensvermittlung durch Vorträge ist eigentlich ein bisschen im Hintergrund.
Nichtsdestotrotz gab es dieses Jahr zwei Zelte. Ich meine auch im Vorjahr auch. Und es ist auch ganz gut bespielt worden. Also es gab auch dankenswerterweise hitzefrei für eine gewisse Pause. Für eine gewisse Zeit, das war immer eingeplant. Aber von euch ist wahrscheinlich auch keiner wirklich dazu gekommen, sich Vorträge anzuschauen.
Aber auf dem Kongress auch nicht.
Das Closing hat Tradition, aber das ist auch, weil man dann mehr oder weniger...
Es war einfach auch zu heiß.
Gut, das heißt aber nicht, dass da keine Teilnehmer sind.
Nein, um Gottes Willen. Aber es sind ja hier auch alle eingebunden in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Genau, also wenn du uns fragst, wir sind alle irgendwie mit irgendwas eingebunden. Und für uns, also nicht, dass das keine Rolle spielen würde, aber man muss dann halt so diesen Trade-off machen und sagt, okay, ich bringe mich jetzt mehr auf den Camp ein und schaue mir dann vielleicht die interessanten Inhalte später an.
Ja, bei den Helfern ist es ja eigentlich fast ausschließlich so, dass sie die ganze Zeit während eines Events rumlaufen und anschließend vor allen Dingen von Aufzeichnungen leben.
Man kann eh nicht alles mitnehmen an so einer Veranstaltung. Dafür passiert da einfach viel zu viel. Aber ich denke, das Camp hat sich in den letzten Jahren eben auch sehr dahin entwickelt. Das merkt man auch so, wie die Teilnehmer selber so aufgestellt sind, was die an Infrastruktur auch selber mitbringen. Dass es eben sehr viel mehr ein verteilter Kongress ist. Dass da einfach an sehr vielen Orten sehr viele diverse Dinge stattfinden parallel. Und das ist irgendwie auch der Reiz, einer der Reize des Camps. Das hat man glaube ich auch dieses Jahr extrem gemerkt, dass wir jetzt unabhängig von Vorträgen oder irgendwie so Workshops, Wissensvermittlung, so gerade diese ganze Wir kochen für unsere Gruppe, wir kochen irgendwie auch für die Umliegenden. Wir haben irgendwie Fässer, Bier dabei und irgendwie laden andere Leute ein. Also wie gesagt so dieses, man kommt gemütlich zusammen und schafft dafür die Infrastruktur, um sich gemütlich zu unterhalten bei einem Bier und beim Essen.
Also echtes Socializing.
Auf jeden Fall deutlich mehr als zum Kongress. Das ist eigentlich auch, sagen wir mal ein bisschen, wenn man in die Zukunft blickt, sicherlich einer der Trends, die sich auch noch verstärken, die sich noch verstärken werden, weil das Gesamtwissen um diese Veranstaltung natürlich auch ansteigt. Das ist auch beim Kongress so. Mittlerweile haben wir keine Ahnung. Aber Tausende von Menschen, die mehr oder weniger regelmäßig auf diesen Kongress kommen und eine sehr gute Vorstellung davon haben, was der Kongress ist, auch einen eigenen Wunsch mitbringen, wie er zu sein hat und auch wissen, wie sie sich da einbringen, damit das eben auch stattfindet. Und beim Camp ist es etwas schwieriger, weil die Komplexität der Veranstaltung natürlich viel größer ist und natürlich auch dadurch, dass es nur alle vier Jahre stattfindet. Also man kann nicht sagen, ja nächstes Jahr machen wir das so, weil da ist halt kein nächstes Jahr. Von daher wird es immer eine Herausforderung bleiben. So oder so haben die Leute sich dran gewöhnt und wissen irgendwie, was sie dabei haben müssen. Also ist ja auch so, dass zum Camp hast du auch viel mehr Gestaltungsfreure. Zum Kongress bist du halt in diesem Haus drinnen, hast relativ wenig Platz. Also gerade wenn es um Sackcenter oder Assembly Space geht, dann hast du halt irgendwie deine zwei Tische, wo du halt irgendwie deinen Computer entscheiden kannst und vielleicht irgendwie noch ein bisschen Nütztation. Wohingegen du irgendwie beim Camp hast du halt diverse Pavillons. Du kannst dich halt irgendwie ausrichten, in denen du sagst, wir wollen jetzt kochen. Du tust dich vielleicht sogar mit ein paar anderen Spaces zusammen. Also wie es zum Beispiel für das BR Village gewesen ist. Das war halt irgendwie, wir wollten mit der Seabase und mit den ganzen Berliner Local Hacker und Makerspaces was zusammen machen, wo dann auch jeder Space sich irgendwie so ein bisschen auf was spezialisiert hat. Also die einen haben gekocht, die anderen haben eine Bar gemacht, die anderen haben ein Vortragsprogramm gemacht.
Und da hast du halt irgendwie viel mehr Freiheiten auf diesem Camp.
Also allein auch durch die Fläche und durch die halt, also durch den Fakt, dass halt einfach vorher nichts da ist und du halt irgendwie alles selber gestalten kannst und musst.
Und eine Sache fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen. Wir haben irgendwie überhaupt noch nicht so richtig die Location gehypt um das, was die anderen Locations nicht hatten. Wer von euch war baden?
Am zwei Tage nach dem Campende. Also die erste Location hatte auch einen See, muss man mal dazu sagen. Der ist umgekippt, also während des Camps noch. Was ich an diesem Gelände extrem gut fand, ist, dass es eine super gute Mischung war zwischen Freiflächen, Gebäuden, Bäumen. Es war alles da. Für die einzelnen Projekte, die du machen musst, gab es auch ordentliche Punkte, die dazu gepasst haben. Dann gab es trotzdem noch die guten Sichtachsen. Die Rakete stand zentral, du hast sie von überall gesehen. Der Fernsehtum, den die Base aufgebaut hatte, war auch sehr zentral. Das hat alles ziemlich gut im Gesamtbild gepasst.
Es gab die Rakete, die stand auf dem sogenannten Marktplatz. Dort, das war die gedachte zentrale Party Area. Du bist ein bisschen skeptisch, Tim?
Nein, ich bin nicht skeptisch. Party Area würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen. Aber der Marktplatz war gedacht als Treffpunkt. Das war die primäre Funktion, die man dem Ort zugedacht hat. Das hat teilweise funktioniert. Ich denke, dem Ort haben, das kann man im Nachhinein analysieren. Das war vorher nicht unbedingt so absehbar. Das Angebot war Platz, das ist eigentlich immer gut. Schön ist es da gewesen. Es gab Essen, es gab Trinken, es gab eine große Bar, es gab da sehr viele interessante Foodstände. Aber was glaube ich einerseits ein Versäumnis war, dass es relativ wenig Hackspace gab. Es gab da irgendwie keine Sonnenzelte. Es gab Sonnenzelte, aber da waren keine Tische, da war kein Strom. Man konnte sich da nicht einfach mal gemütlich mit dem Laptop hinsetzen und mal ein paar Stunden hacken. Das war sicherlich so ein kleines Versäumnis. Und in meinen Augen hat auch das Bear Village, vor allem da mit diesem zentralen Ort, mit eigener Bühne und dem Tippy, auch noch mal so einen zusätzlichen Sozialraum geschaffen, der im Prinzip diesem Marktplatz auch sehr gut zu Gesicht gestanden hätte. Dass man da mehr hat als nur eine PA für einen DJ. Man hätte da meiner Auffassung nach auch genauso gut eine Eröffnungsveranstaltung machen können und eben auch so ein bisschen Konzert-Content und andere Sachen. Das hätte da prima gepasst und dann sicherlich dem Ort noch sehr viel mehr diese Rolle zugeschrieben, wie es ursprünglich gedacht war.
Das BR gucken wir uns gleich noch an.
Was ich auch ziemlich cool fand, war der Hügel mit dem Aussichtsturm. Aussichtsturm kann man das so nennen? Das war supergeil, da konnte man richtig schön drüberschauen. Da sind auch die sehr schönen Fotos her, wo die Blitzenden drauf zu sehen sind.
Was mich fasziniert hat, das ist ja auch nicht neu, aber das hat in dieser Art und Weise, glaube ich, sehr gut funktioniert, war das Family Village. Das war richtig top. Gerade dadurch, dass es auch direkt am Wasser lag. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit dieser kleine Minizoo da genutzt wurde.
Und der Ofen, den sie gebaut haben. Da war richtig was los auch.
Family Village war einfach perfekt, kann man sagen. Es waren, glaube ich, noch nie so viele Kinder da. Das hat irgendwie wunderbar funktioniert. Ich kann das nicht quantifizieren, aber es waren unheimlich viele Kinder da. Zahlen, schwierig. Wenn man das jetzt durchgezählt hätte, wäre ich nicht überrascht, wenn es 100 sind oder so. Also richtig viele. Für die gab es ein eigenes Küchenzelt, für die gab es ein Lego-Bastelzelt, wo auch einzelne Workshops stattgefunden haben. Dann war dieser kleine See direkt am Gelände auch da. Da waren sehr viele Bäume, es war schön schattig. Die Eisenbahn fuhr natürlich auch ganz romantisch da durch. Das hat einfach wunderbar funktioniert. Das war perfekt.
Bei diesem ganzen Family Village, welche Villages habt ihr sonst noch? Man muss da vielleicht erst mal erklären, das haben wir auch noch nicht getan, wie das Ganze überhaupt noch aufgebaut ist. Wir haben gesagt, es gibt diesen Marktplatz, und es gab das Bär Village. Das impliziert erst mal, dass es Villages gibt. Das haben wir so ein bisschen vorweggenommen, als wir gesagt haben, da haben Leute selbst bestimmt irgendwas gemacht, irgendwelche Angebote gemacht. Das war in sogenannten Villages organisiert. Welche Villages sind euch abseits vom Bär jetzt noch mal so aufgefallen?
Also vielleicht erst mal von vornherein.
Beim Camp ist es ja so, dass du in der Regel mit den Leuten aus der gleichen Stadt oder aus dem gleichen Hacker-Space oder ähnliche Interessen zusammen sich findest und dann auch zusammen zähltest. Und das ist halt so der Hintergedanke, der die Villages ausmacht. Das heißt, du hast dann Gruppen, die sich im Vorhinein zusammenfinden, die sagen, wir sind 30 bis 40 Leute, wir würden gerne so und so viel Space haben, wir machen die und die coolen Projekte. Und dann gibt es halt die Village Orga, die dann halt gesagt, wo sie dann praktisch ihre Plätze finden können, beziehungsweise so ein bisschen so ein Gehen und Nehmen. Sie sagen, wir würden gerne dahin. Und die Village Orga sagt, ihr seid aber viel zu klein, um diesen ganzen Platz einzunehmen. Und dann gibt es halt so eine Diskussion. Jetzt ist irgendwas kaputt. Und das macht eigentlich den Großteil tatsächlich das Camp selber aus. Du hast halt diesen Marktplatz, der relativ viel Fläche hatte. Und alles andere war eigentlich, neben den Vortragszelten, war eigentlich mehr oder weniger Villages. Also sei es halt Family Village, BR Village oder halt die ganzen anderen Hackers. Ich glaube, wir hatten über 100 Villages. 156 habe ich jetzt im Kopf. Also irgendwie auf jeden Fall eine enorm große Zahl. Also beginnt mit drei, vier Leuten. Die sind jetzt das keine Ahnung Village bis hin zu wirklich. Ich glaube, BR war so oder Family Village war so eines des Größten. Wir hatten wirklich mehreren hundert Leute. Ich glaube, dass BR hat die meiste Fläche eingenommen. Und BR ist in meinem Verständnis auch schon eher so, dass die Idee eines Village Clusters gewesen, weil sich da sozusagen mehrere Gruppen, die sich auch einzeln hätten als Village verstehen können, dann sozusagen noch mal zusammengerottet haben in so einem geografischen Bereich.
Das ist auch bei den Münchnern so gewesen. Die haben mit den Franken zusammen gestanden. Entschuldigung. Dann gab es das Heckzugtum. Ich nehme an, das war Paraborn, da die Ecke. Würde ich jetzt einfach vermuten, ohne das zu wissen. Meinst du?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Weiß das irgendjemand? Gut, falls jemand weiß. Dann gab es noch, was ich sehr lustig fand, die Kinky Geeks. Habt ihr die Kinky Geeks angeguckt?
Ich habe sie nicht angeguckt, aber ich habe ihre Präsenz zur Kenntnis genommen.
Ich habe es mir angeschaut.
Auch da gibt es ein... Sie haben zumindest ein Maßgeblich... Sie haben auf jeden Fall maßgeblich in einem wichtigen, lehrreichen Film des Zards eine Rolle gespielt. Und auch...
Ich habe sie nicht gesehen.
Also auf jeden Fall gucken. Auf jeden Fall.
Wir hatten ja irgendwie das Problem, dass es, also es war ja auf dem Acker, das heißt irgendwie ist potenziell auch Unwettergefahr und irgendwie Zelte fliegen durch die Gegend. Und das Zert hat sich irgendwie den Spaß gemacht und hat gesagt, wir haben hier das Problem mit losen Zelten, dann drehen wir doch mal einen Lehrfilm aller Sendungen mit der Maus und erklären, wie man irgendwie sein Zelt absichert. Also der ist wirklich großartig, super eingesprochen, super, die Leute, die da mitgespielt haben, das passt einfach perfekt. Also muss man sich auf jeden Fall angucken. Nee, gibt's auch auf Media, denke ich.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob's den auf Media gibt. Es gibt den auf jeden Fall.
Dann gibt's den auf jeden Fall bald auf Media.
Genau, das ist Bernd.
Es gibt den bestimmt schon in den Show Notes.
Genau, in die Show Notes. Die Show Notes haben das gekovvert. Wunderbar. Genau. Und das Ganze ist, glaube ich, auch mit zurückzuführen darauf, dass wir die Besonderheit hatten, dass der Ralf Kaspers einen Vortrag gehalten hat. Das ist jener welcher, der auch unter anderem bei der Sendung mit der Maus immer wieder Beiträge abliefert. Genau, und er hat halt quasi einfach erzählt, wie man Dinge knackig rüberbringt und da hat sich das Zert nicht lange bitten lassen.
Also ist es erst nach dem Vortrag entstanden, oder was? Soweit ich weiß, ja. Das sind eben so die ganzen Sachen, die man immer erst ein, zwei Wochen nach der Veranstaltung mitkriegt, was da alles so an lustigen Sachen passiert ist. Auch so diese ganzen coolen, kleinen Snorts zwischendurch, die auch in der Abschlussveranstaltung nochmal zur Sprache kamen.
Erzählt mal, wie war denn das? Da gab es irgendwie einen schönen Snort mit einer unter Wasser stehenden Stromleitung?
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal auf diesen Vorfall mit der Wettersituation eingehen.
Das macht das halt etwas klarer.
Also ist ja Sommer und wie wir alle wissen, es kann schönes Wetter sein und wenn es dann mal schlecht wird, dann wird es auch schnell mal sehr schlecht. Und so war es dann auch. Es zog also eine Gewitterfront heran, die uns dann auch voll erwischt hat. Also es hat wohl mindestens einen Blitzeinschlag irgendwo auf den Camp gegeben. Es ist jetzt keiner zu Schaden gekommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber gibt. Der nächste Blitzeinschlag war so wie 150 Meter weg und hat auch einen Baum richtig getroffen und zermatscht. Im Norden oder im Süden? Als es schon vorbei war? Ich weiß, dass das Ding über uns rüberzog. Aber es gab einen richtig lauten. Ich meinte, es war richtig laut. Da war der Unterschied zwischen den beiden. Ich glaube, es war im Norden. Ja, da gab es dann auch tatsächlich einen Evakuierungsplan, der aktiviert wurde. Was dazu führte, dass viele Leute aufgefordert wurden, ihre Zelte zu verlassen und sich in die Schutzräume zu begeben. Das waren natürlich vor allem Autos. Oder das Getränkelager. Das Getränkelager.
Oder ein Sprinter.
Es gab auch, glaube ich, ein Gebäude von dem C-Geleitpark, das da in Fragen kam, etc. Das ist an sich gut verlaufen, muss man sagen. Also nicht, dass jetzt alle evakuiert wurden. Und sicherlich standen auch nicht alle in wirklich blitzgesicherten Zelten. Aber hat immerhin geklappt. Und danach hat es nochmal so eine halbe Stunde richtig ordentlich geregnet. Also so richtig doll geklappt, das nicht. Also in der Theorie war das irgendwie sicherlich gut durchdacht gewesen. Aber in der Praxis, also es war auf jeden Fall, das hätte deutlich besser laufen können.
Mit anderen Worten, wir brauchen auf anderen Camps mehr Schlechtwetter-Situationen, um das mal perfekt zu trainieren.
Ja, so wie das halt immer ist.
Beim ersten Mal gehen halt irgendwie noch Sachen schief und man lernt auch draus.
Aber ich meine, von der Theorie war es auf jeden Fall richtig, das zu machen. Also weil so ein Zeltplatz mit Gewitter drüber, das ist einfach mal echt gefährlich, mit Bäumen, die dann auf Zelte fallen können oder Zelte, die irgendwo einschlagen in der Nähe.
Aber es gab halt auch, es gab Kommunikation. Also ich kann mich jetzt nicht wirklich beklagen. Es hätte sicherlich an einigen Stellen besser laufen können. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wir waren immer informiert. Was Sache war, stand halt keiner im strömenden Regen.
Ja doch, genau das war das Problem. Die Leute standen im strömenden Regen, weil halt diese Evakuierung einfach zu spät losgetreten wurde. Das heißt irgendwie, dann sind die, die das Zelt halt rumgelaufen hat, gesagt, wieso jetzt verlasst mal bitte irgendwie das Zelt, was halt total Sinn macht. Aber wenn es halt irgendwie vor zwei Minuten angefangen hat, im Ström zu regnen, ist es schwierig, die Leute zu überzeugen, jetzt nochmal das Zelt zu verlassen. Das heißt, man hätte es einfach mal eine Viertelstunde früher machen können, dann wäre es auf jeden Fall irgendwie deutlich in geordneteren Bahnen abgelaufen.
Auf der anderen Seite, gerade so ein Gewitter, es sind ja mehrere Gewitter auch einfach schlicht in der Gaffnung an uns vorbeigezogen.
Zwei Tage vorher gab es doch auch schon mal ein Gewitter, wo es dann ein Lärz auch richtig geballert hat. Und da war sehr lustig, da fuhr die Lebensrettungsgesellschaft ganz entspannt über den Platz und sagte immer durch, Moin, Moin, wir erwarten in den nächsten Stunden ein wenig Wind und etwas Regen. Wo wir dann so dastehen und sagen, okay, ein wenig Wind, Moin, Moin, okay, was machen wir jetzt?
Nüscht. Das war aber nicht hier auf dem Camp, oder?
Es war auf dem Camp, aber es war zwei Tage vorher.
Das war die erste Unwetterwärme. Also da war es tatsächlich auch so, dass ein Gewitterfront irgendwie angerückt ist, die sich aber glücklicherweise genauso um Mildenberg rumgetreten hat, die Hälfte am Norden, die Hälfte im Süden vorbeigegangen. Und es war abzusehen, dass das passiert, aber wir dachten uns, naja, lassen wir es mal trotzdem durchlaufen, dann können die Leute schon mal irgendwie ihre Zelte sichern, weil es kommt auf jeden Fall in den nächsten Tagen noch ein großes Wunder her. Daher war das gar nicht so verkehrt, das so laufen zu lassen. Es hat auf jeden Fall dann geregnet, dann war es halt auch nass, was jetzt auf dem Gelände auch nicht so das große Problem war, weil wir natürlich den Vorteil hatten. Ziegeleihpark heißt, das Ganze ist ein Industriegelände. Da sind schon immer große Geräte, Bagger etc. unterwegs gewesen. Das heißt, dieser ganze Rasen, den wir genutzt haben, ist halt, soweit ich weiß, durchgehend unterschottert. Sprich, da weicht jetzt nicht gleich alles auf. Es gab natürlich die eine oder andere Pfütze, aber halt jetzt nichts Dramatisches, dass sich da riesige Löcher auftun oder man in großen Wasserschlammen wandelt.
Es war keine Schlammschlacht in keiner Weise.
Es war keine Schlammschlacht, überhaupt nicht, aber es hat schon ganz ordentlich geregnet und danach hatten die Nerds halt ihren Spaß und dann ist halt diese coole Installation, wo dann irgendwie so eine dieser Pfützen dazu genutzt wurden, so ganz dekorativ, da so eine stinknormale Dreifachstecker-Verteiler-Wohnzimmer-Dose im Wasser zu versenken, die so sehr, naja, wasserüberdeckt einfach total bedrohlich aussah.
Das dampfte da, glaube ich.
Ja, es wäre halt keinem aufgefallen, wenn sie nicht noch so klug gewesen, noch so einen Würfel Trockenheiss dazu zu schmeißen. Womit das dann halt auch noch so nebelschwaden.
Mit anderen Worten, was immer daran angeschlossen war, war in Wirklichkeit auf Batterie.
Da war halt gar nichts dran angeschlossen. Das war halt einfach so ne temporäre... Es war ein Baustrahler angeschlossen, der aber batteriebetrieben war. Sie haben auch echt ne gute Performance dazu gemacht. Also mit rumlaufen und so. Fasst ihr nicht an und immer so runter und... Also es war schon ganz lustig. Also man hätte merken können, das ist irgendwie nicht... Super Nerd-Humor. Sind auf jeden Fall einige Leute an die Decke gegangen. Da seid ihr wahnsinnig verängsheit.
Das klingt doch erstmal sehr, sehr flottig.
Ja, hat also eigentlich alles funktioniert. Und es war auch mal ganz interessant zu sehen, es gab ja dann auch die Entscheidung wegen des Gewitters, den Strom komplett abzuschalten. Also nicht nur die Generatoren auszuschalten, sondern die Generatoren mussten ausgeschaltet werden, weil man halt die Kabel trennen wollte. Weil, keine Ahnung, das kann ich nicht so richtig bewerten. Schon halt sein kann, so ein Generator ist, sagen wir mal, durchaus so ein Blitzmagnet. Und wäre es da halt reingeschossen, hätte es sich dann eben auch durch das ausgelegte Stromnetz leichter verteilen können, wo natürlich dann viele Geräte dranhängen und Zelte und so weiter. Das wollte man vermeiden. Und war interessant zu sehen, dass man einfach dieses ganze Camp mal eine Viertelstunde runterfahren kann und wieder hochfahren kann. Und danach war es auch alles wieder bunt und Internet gab und deckt funktionierte. Also auch ein ganz ordentlicher Test.
Gut, dann wollen wir uns jetzt noch gleich die Nerd News anhören. Und dann geht es gleich noch weiter hier im Chaos Radio.
Die Nerd News Mit Web.de und GMX wollen zwei deutsche E-Mail-Anbieter, die zum Internetkonzern United Internet gehören, auf den Internetstandard Dane setzen. Mittels Dane können beliebige Provider untereinander die E-Mails ihrer Kunden verschlüsselt austauschen. Damit kehrt United Internet der proprietären Insellösung E-Mail Made in Germany den Rücken, mit der deutsche Anbieter ohne Dane untereinander E-Mails verschlüsselt austauschen wollten. Auch die Regierungs-Server auf Bund.de verwenden bereits Dane. Auch wenn durch Dane noch keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung gewährleistet wird, ist Dane eine Verbesserung gegenüber der sonst gewöhnlich unverschlüsselten E-Mail-Übertragung zwischen zwei Anbietern. Sicherheitsforscher haben aus einem internetfähigen Kühlschrank von Samsung das Google Login des Besitzers ausgelesen. Dabei machten sie sich zunutze, dass die Software die SSL-Zertifikate nicht prüft, die der Webserver zur Erstellung einer sicheren Verbindung vorweist. So ist der Kühlschrank durch eine Man-in-the-Middle-Attacke angreifbar. Da zum Funktionsumfang des Smart Fridges eine Google-Kalender-Anzeige gehört, kann ein Angreifer so beispielsweise die Google-Zugangsdaten auslesen, um an das Gmail-Contr des Kühlschrankbesitzers zu kommen. Samsung will nun nachbessern. Die Bundesregierung drängt auf eine Einführung der Vectoring-Technologie, um VDSL-Zugänge zu beschleunigen. Beim Vectoring werden mehrere Kupferadern gebündelt, um eine schnellere Datenübertragung mit bis zu 100 Megabit pro Sekunde zu ermöglichen. Ohne Vectoring liegt das Limit bei 50 Megabit pro Sekunde. Aus technischen Gründen benötigt beim Vectoring ein anbieter-exklusiven Zugriff auf einen Hauptverteiler, um in dessen Nahbereich Vectoring anbieten zu können. Dieses Privileg soll nach einem Bericht des Handelsplottes vollständig an die Telekom gehen. Das Bundeskanzleramt und die Ministerien für Wirtschaft und Verkehr drängen die Bundesnetzagentur dem Bericht zufolge zu einem Vertrag mit der Telekom. Darin soll diese sich im Gegenzug verpflichten, 80 Prozent der Haushalte mit Vectoring zu versorgen. Damit würden andere Telekommunikationsunternehmen Zugang zu den 8.000 Hauptverteilern der Telekom verlieren. Die Wettbewerber haben Klage angekündigt.
T-T-
Willkommen zurück zum Chaos Radio 215, wo wir uns heute über das Chaos Communication Congress Camp unterhalten wollen. Und zu uns auf die Couch ist der Sef gekommen. Hallo. Hallo. Und du hattest eine ganz besondere Rolle, nämlich du hast das BR Village mit organisiert. Das ist das Village vom Chaos Computer Club Berlin und Freunde, kann man das so sagen?
Genau, vom Chaos Computer Club und anderen Berliner Hacker-Spaces, wie den Lichtpiraten, Afra, RFA, C-Base. C-Base hatte noch ihr eigenes Village.
Das war ein Village Cluster, haben wir das gerade definiert.
Genau, der Village Cluster. Wie seid ihr zu diesem Village gekommen? Was habt ihr da für ein Konzept verfolgt? Kann man das überhaupt so fragen? Oder war das einfach so, lasst mal machen, super Sache?
Es war eigentlich nicht mehr das.
Ja, lass mal machen, geil, wir machen.
Camp. Okay, und wie sah das dann praktisch aus? Was habt ihr da auf die Wiese gestellt?
Also wir haben als erstes mal die Tippis, den Dom und die Infrastruktur auf den Platz gestellt. Und der Rest waren die verschiedenen Tippis.
Wir hatten ein Tippi.
Es gab ein Doppeltippi.
Ich glaube, da stellt sich jemand etwas unter den Scheffel gerade, weil diese Tippis waren fantastisch. Also darunter muss man auch mal sagen, das war so der Ort, wo man zum einen net chillen konnte. Da war die Bar, die Ajan unter einem nett bespielt hat. Und von dort aus hatte man auch einen herrlichen Blick auf die Bühne. Eine Bühne, da gab es auch noch eine lustige Geschichte, die war irgendwie nicht so die richtige Bühne.
Das Zelt über der Bühne war nicht das erste Zelt, das über dieser Bühne stand.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen rumprobiert. Wir hatten erst das eine Tab, dann hatten wir das nächste Tab. Wir haben das alles ein bisschen mehrfach ausprobiert und haben uns dann am Ende für die Variante entschieden, die dann da stand.
Okay, aber es hat ja doch ganz ordentlich funktioniert. Tim kann da sicherlich irgendwie ein Lied von singen. Der hat nämlich da ein paar Mal auf der Bühne Sachen gemacht, nämlich ein paar seiner Podcasts. Zwischen Tippy und Bühne hat auch ganz gut Publikum gepasst. Auch das haben wir, glaube ich, mehrfach sehen können. Und als ganz besonderen Gast hatten wir dann ja auch noch eine Band, nämlich...
The Incredible Herringgedeck.
Genau.
Ja, ein super Combo. Wenn ihr ihn nicht kennt, schnell mal bei Google eingeben. Sehr lustig, sehr unterhaltsam, sehr passend. Ich fand das extrem passend. Also das war einfach so vom Mindset her genau das Richtige, finde ich. Das hat einfach super gepasst. Piepshow hatten wir auch noch. Ja, möchtest du das gleich ausrühren?
Das würde ich jetzt aber auch gerne von dir hören.
Von mir jetzt?
Ja, wenn du das ansprichst. Mir ist das jetzt auch tatsächlich völlig...
Es gibt was, was du verpasst hast auf dem Web.
Ausgrinde die Piepshow.
Wir sollten unbedingt sagen, dass die Piepshow da war. Und die Piepshow war da. Wahnsinn.
Die Piepshow ist einfach so ein kleiner roter Minitrack, der da noch aufgelaufen ist und nochmal so seinen eigenen kleinen Mini-Dancefloor temporär an einem Abend eröffnet hat und lustige Späße mit den Teilnehmern durchgeführt hat.
Ja, und Interaktion mit den Teilnehmern. Die Teilnehmer konnten bestimmen, durch Drücken von Knöpfen, was passieren soll.
Was passieren soll? Ist das einigermaßen safer work, wenn ich jetzt frage, was da passieren konnte?
Alkohol gab es dann, letztendlich.
Ausschließlich? Wir hatten auch die endlosen Leute, oder?
Es gab da auch soziale Interaktionen, die man aufrufen konnte, aber da möchte ich jetzt auch nicht so im Detail drauf eingehen.
Bleiben wir dabei. Es gab eine Piepshow.
Es war auf jeden Fall gut besucht und mit großartiger Stimmung und war wieder so ein kleiner Fnord auf dieser Veranstaltung, der so ganz unangekündigt auf einmal aufpoppte und dann irgendwann wieder verschwand.
Fnords sind überhaupt immer sehr beliebt. Also das funktioniert. Ich kenne das tatsächlich hauptsächlich irgendwie vom Kongress, aber auf dem Camp hat das irgendwie nochmal seine besondere Würze. Das ist irgendwie nochmal deutlich unerwarteter.
Ja, genauso wie dieser Party Train. Also ich meine, wir haben das ja schon ein paarmal erzählt, dass es halt eine Zuginfrastruktur gibt, die ja auf diesem Ziegelei-Park ohnehin immer in Betrieb ist. Damit fahren dann halt die Museumsbesucher über dieses Gelände und auch teilweise über dieses Gelände hinaus und lassen sich dann eben im Vorbeifahren das ein oder andere Feature dieses Ziegelei-Parks erläutern. Das fand ja dann auch skurrilerweise parallel auf dem Camp auch statt, dass da halt so Auswärtige über diesen Acker gefahren wurde und dann war halt einfach mal die Attraktion ausgetauscht.
Auch während des Aufbaus schon.
Auch während des Aufbaus.
Jeden Tag mehrfach.
Hier und schauen sie mal links und die Zelte und so. Und ja, außerdem kann man halt auch einen richtigen Rundkurs befahren auf dem Kerngelände des Camps und dann gab es halt so ein Party-Train. Wer hat das überhaupt angeleiert irgendwie?
Das hat man gemacht.
Das hat man gemacht und jetzt noch ein paar andere Vögel haben dann halt einfach diesen Zug dekoriert und er hatte dann seine eigene Cocktail-Bar, einen Wagen war halt ein Bälle-Bad.
Wo obskurerweise die Bälle öfters mal sortiert vorbeifuhren.
Jeden Morgen waren die sortiert. Jeden Morgen waren die farblich sortiert. Herr Munzberg, frag nicht, wer das war. Das Beste ist, dass am ersten Tag, da hast du mir relativ verzweifelt, neben mir stand und meinte, da waren überall Kinder und die Eltern waren nicht zu finden. Und am nächsten Tag war Volker richtig ein Schild dran, nur für große Kinder ab 18 Jahre. Und wir sind wirklich dann so, los, komm, wir haben einen Zug. Und dann stand da so ein Mädchen neben mir, darf mir heute nur große Kinder rein. Ich darf da jetzt nicht rein, hier gehts rein. Das fanden die richtig scheiße.
Nur für die Großen und so, voll gemein.
Aber die Nerds hatten ja eh traditionell Anspruch auf ein Bällebad.
Ja, aber das war schon ein bisschen eine fiese Aktion. Über die Argumentation konnte ich nachvollziehen, dass sie organisatorisch in dem Moment sich nicht ausreichend aufgestellt sahen, dafür die Sicherheit der Kinder zu sorgen. Zumal es wohl auch vorgekommen ist, dass Kinder so während der Fahrt ausgestiegen sind. Was nicht so ein mega Problem ist bei größeren Kindern, weil der fuhr ja jetzt nicht sonderlich schnell.
Im Zweifelsfall, ich hab mir öfters mal überlegt, die Bahn zu nehmen, um schneller von A nach B zu kommen. Ich hab mir dann überlegt, dass das Laufen die effizientere Variante ist.
Ja, es ist entspannt. Aber da kann man auf jeden Fall noch dran arbeiten. Aber trotzdem war dieser Partytrain von seiner ganzen Erscheinung her einfach ein super Ding. Man steht halt irgendwo so rum und auf einmal kommt so eine johlende Partymasse, die auf diesem Zug in Schrittgeschwindigkeit durch die Gegend geht, Cocktails von vorne nach hinten durchreicht.
Und in der Nacht dann auch noch schön beleuchtet.
Schön beleuchtet natürlich. Also das hat bei mir wieder alles richtig gepasst. Und diese Kreativität der Teilnehmer, das finde ich, das macht auch diesen Reiz aus. Und dieses Draußen sein und diese 24-Stunden-Bespielung, das macht auch alle so verrückt. Ich meine, so am ersten Tag sind immer alle noch voll gestresst und ankommen und gucken. Und was gibt es denn eigentlich so? Und dann nach dem ersten Mal Schlafen hat man das dann so halbwegs gescannt und man weiß, wo was ist. Und dann bricht irgendwie der Wahnsinn aus. Das ist ja auch auf dem Kongress eigentlich ähnlich. Dann kommen dann alle auf so verrückte Ideen. Und ich glaube, nach zwei Tagen hatte dann diese Zugbespielung dann auch schon, muss ich nochmal kurz ausholen, also die C-Base hat ja auch so eine eigene Blinken-Lights-artige Installation, diese Martelights, diese aus Lampen, Innenmarte, Flaschen, Innenmarte, Kisten, die dann so quasi durch den Boden durchscheinen. Das stand ohnehin schon in der Nähe der Tracks. Und dann, weiß ich nicht, haben die da so einen GPS-Trecker noch auf dem Zug draufgehangen. Auf jeden Fall waren sie in der Lage, auf diesem Pixel-Display den Rundkurs anzuzeigen. Und es blinkte immer an der Stelle, wo sich gerade der Zug befand. Also das ist einfach wieder so eine göttliche Nerd-Installation vom Feinsten.
Jeden Abend gab es was Neues zu sehen in den Villages. Jedes Village hat sich eigentlich verändert. Ja, zum Beispiel eben das Martelight, das dann den Rundkurs angezeigt hat.
Das ihr übrigens normalerweise in der Sea-Base bestaunen könnt.
Genau, die Sea-Base hat diesmal wirklich ziemlich gebrockt.
Also es gab einen 1 zu 1-Clone, das habe ich ja auch im Teaser geschrieben, wie es denn kam, dass auf einmal der Fernsehturm mitten in der brandenburgischen Einöde stand. Und sie haben es echt gut versteckt. Sie haben die ganzen Einzelteile nämlich so hangar gleich in einem Zelt erst vorgehalten und dann stand auf einmal eine Kopie des Fernsehturms inklusive rotierendem...
Das wusste keiner?
Das wusste nur ganz wenige. Und sie hatten halt dieses Workshop-Zelt, glaube ich, was noch nicht in Betrieb war, irgendeins dieser Zelte, die nicht an Tag 1 in Betrieb waren. Genau. Und ich bin da nur, weil ich da quasi Infrastruktur raus tragen musste, reingegangen und wurde auch auferlegt und so, dass dann wirklich als große Überraschung dieser Fernsehtürme als 1 zu 1 Kopie natürlich doch deutlich kleiner mit rotierender Kuppel an den Start gehen konnte.
Also dicke Props an die Base, das war wirklich ganz großes Kino. Aber auch diese hell 9000 Installationen, wer hat das nochmal gebracht? ICMP oder wo war das? Erlang? Was? Ja genau, war bei euch. Also bei Erlang. Ich will ja nichts falsches sagen jetzt. Aber irgendwo so in dieser Straße war das. Auch ganz toll. Also diese ganzen Kleinigkeiten, einfach schöne Sachen und das erfreut mich auch besonders zu sehen, dass das einfach in zunehmendem Maße auch so gesehen wird, dass das Camp auch so ein Outlet ist für so schönen Wahnsinn. Dass man über das Camp so nachdenkt, dass man sagt, da muss man was Besonderes hinstellen. Es gab auch, ich fühl mich nur halb qualifiziert, diese Aussage auch nur zu wiederholen, aber so aus amerikanischen Kreisen kam auch schon so, ja das ist irgendwie so Burning Man ohne Wüste, wo man so Sachen hinbringt, wurde jetzt zwar am Schluss nicht alles verbrannt, aber so dieser Gedanke einfach für begrenzte Zeit, für so einige wenige Tage einfach so den schönstmöglichen Kunst-Base zu bauen und dann eben mit diesem spezifischen Nerd-Ansatz mit Technologie und das dann eben auch noch mal besonders sophisticated zu machen, das dann so zu bauen und danach ist es halt weg und wer nicht da war, hat es halt nicht gesehen und wird so nie nachvollziehen können, das ist schon so einer der Reize, der von dieser Veranstaltung ausgeht.
Das sind immer das, wo man seinen Kollegen sagt, ihr müsst dahin kommen, ihr müsst dahin kommen, ja, ja, ja, dann verpeilen sie.
Camping und so, ich hasse Camping.
Und wenn sie dann hinterher in der Zeitung lesen oder von Freunden hören, was da alles im Einzelnen abging, dann ärgern sie sich Grün und Blau. Ja, das ist ja schon. Habt ihr sonst noch irgendwelche besonderen Fnords, die euch besonders aufgefallen sind?
Oder hast du deine Liste schon durch?
Nein, ich hab meine Liste noch nicht durch, aber ich wollte noch gekonnt die zwei Minuten bis halb überbrücken.
Noch ein Anekdötchen.
Ach ja, genau. An dem Seen, dem besagten See, in dem ich persönlich sehr oft war, also sprich eigentlich bei jedem Weg zurück zum Backstage, immer erst mal kurz im See, weil es war einfach zu heiß. Da war dann ein Schild, da stand dann irgendwie No FKK. Das stand schon, als wir zum Aufbau angekommen sind dort. Und wir haben uns immer angeguckt, so, no FKK, naja gut, okay, Badehose, okay. Und wir haben die ganzen Tage immer gesagt, ja, macht das jetzt inner ab oder lassen wir das jetzt dran? Also es war kein richtiges Schild, es war so nur mit Pappe so drangeklebt. Und wir haben dann die ganze Zeit immer, ja eigentlich muss das weg, weil was soll das? Hier so viele Kinder sind hier dann nicht mehr nachher, wenn dann erst mal zu ist und ja. Und dann haben wir am ersten Tag, haben dann selber und ich dort gesessen, völlig erschlagen und sitzen da und gucken. Und es ist immer so, so ein Nerd geht so hin, guckt sich kurz um, reißt das Schild ab und geht weg. Ich sag, jetzt haben wir den historischen Moment mit ermäbt. Und es hing da ein neues Schild dran, da stand aber No Glass drauf, weil die Flaschen dann dort doch ein bisschen gefährlich waren. Also super Sache, wir sind da dafür oder dagegen. Oder naja, irgendwas. Gegen Flaschen. Wir sind gegen Flaschen.
Flaschen kann eh keiner brauchen. Und die andere Sache, die jetzt leider nur die Leute sehen, die dich im Stream sehen, du hast die wunderschöne Kapitänsmütze auf. Ja, hervorragend. Das war nämlich auch so dieser besondere Reiz irgendwie, dass ihr als Orga-Team so dieses BR-Alles-Alles-Fail so stilistisch rübergebracht habt. Aber organisationsmäßig war ja dann doch irgendwie alles gut.
Ja, bestens vorbereitet und so. Ganz klar, von Langehand geplant. Sepp, sag du mal was.
Wir sind natürlich nicht fertig geworden. Also wir hatten da noch ein bisschen mehr.
In Betriebnahme vor Fertigstellung heißt das. Das ist der Untertitel dieses Projekts.
Es war dann irgendwie so an Tag Null. Ja, so richtig weit seid ihr aber noch nicht. Ich sag, ey, das gehört zum Konzept. Hast du mal noch Tausende? Wir brauchen noch ein bisschen mehr Budget. Ja, aber irgendwie war es ja dann doch ganz geil.
Ja, schwierig zu toppen.
Ja, es war einfach ein super Ding. Ich kann da als Außenstehender sprechen. Ich habe zwar am Bär teilgenommen, aber die Organisation eigentlich im Vorfeld nicht wirklich begleitet, außer dass ich ein paar Anforderungen mit reingegossen habe. Es war einfach wunderbar. Erstmal finde ich es super, dieser schämische Blick auf die Berliner Realität. Leben mit Fail. Das ist ja sozusagen das, was man in dieser Stadt dann einfach auch wirklich immer irgendwie hat. Und nichts hat es halt so sehr zum Ausdruck gebracht wie dieser Flughafen. Und das dann einfach so als Titel zu nehmen, das ist einfach perfekt. Also das war einfach ganz großes Kino. Und wie das am Ende auch alles aussah, es war einfach so wunderbar gelebter Trash. Es kam halt irgendwie alles zusammen. Nichts war am Ende so, wie es geplant war. Also zumindest nicht vollständig. Da kam ja noch in den letzten zwei Tage vorher, wo ja dann nochmal irgendwie ein ganzer Lastwagen mit Deko von einer Party rangekarrt. Das stand irgendwie auch nicht auf der Planungsliste.
Dann habe ich noch eine abschließende Frage, kurz bevor wir die Musik anwerfen. Wer von euch hatten dann tatsächlich sein Badge in Betrieb genommen, noch auf dem Camp?
Ich auch nicht.
Keiner.
Da fragst du jetzt glaube ich echt die falschen.
Wir warten bis zum Datengarten.
Aber ich glaube, das haben einige getan. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall einige dabei beobachtet und mit ihnen auch gesprochen darüber, was sie da jetzt gerade versuchen. Wie viele erfolgreiche in Betriebnahmen von ersten Prototypen, von ersten Ideen es gab, vermag ich nicht zu sagen. Das ist natürlich eher was für die Spezialisten. Aber letztlich glaube ich, hat auch niemand die Erwartung gehabt, dass dieses Badge schon auf den Camp zum Einsatz kommt. Das passt dann wunderbar auf den Kongress.
Über dieses Badge unterhalten wir uns gleich nach der kleinen Musik. So, und wir sind zurück im Chaos Radio 2015, in dem wir uns, und diesmal sag ich es richtig, über das Chaos Communication Camp unterhalten.
2015.
2015, also dem Starbuck kann man es auch nicht wirklich recht machen.
Doch, einfach nur richtig machen.
Schon funktioniert es. So, und der, der da so dreckig ins Mikrofon lacht, das ist Tim und als dritte in der Runde haben wir noch die Arianna. So, und ich habe das gerade schon angekündigt. Wir sitzen hier mit drei Leuten, eigentlich mit vier Leuten in der Runde, die alle diesen Badge noch nicht in Betrieb genommen haben.
Also du auch nicht?
Nee, ich auch nicht. Weil, wann denn? Bekanntes Problem. Was wir allerdings mal machen können, ist kurz anreißen, worüber wir hier eigentlich reden, wenn wir von einem Badge reden.
Genau, und warum eigentlich auch? Also es gibt ja diese Tradition auf Hacker-Veranstaltungen, wenn ich mich nicht irre, hat das einen Ursprung, ich glaube die ersten waren so Defcon, kann das sein? Die haben irgendwie angefangen, irgendeine Elektronik auszugeben als Badge. Ich kann mich jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig dran erinnern, was die so... Ich glaube die ersten haben einfach nur geblinkt. Geblinkt, so Elektronik. Das PCB, also die Leiterplatte war irgendwie in einer schicken Form, aber ansonsten hat die glaube ich nicht weiter was gemacht. Genau, daraus hat sich das so ein bisschen entwickelt, und auf dem Camp gab es ja, das war vor vier Jahren mit der Rocket, oder war das noch länger her? Ne, Rocket war vor vier Jahren. Ne, ich glaube das war vor vier Jahren. Vor vier Jahren auf dem Camp war das glaube ich mit der Rocket, also in Raketenform.
Also das war eine Leiterplatte.
Es gab vorher Sputnik, gab es vorher noch.
Es war eine Leiterplatte, muss man nochmal dazu sagen, die aussah wie eine Rakete.
Genau, und Starbuck hat gesagt gerade, vorher gab es Sputnik. Halt doch mal die Kamera. Sputnik, das war ja auch schon im Prinzip so die Idee, das mit dem Checking zu machen. Also man muss sagen, Sputnik war eigentlich insofern, glaube ich, ein Schritt nach vorne. Wann war denn das? Das muss 2008 oder so sein. 2007 rum gewesen sein. Und das war quasi so ein Badge für jeden. Das war so ein aktives RFID-System, womit man halt auch gleich getrackt werden konnte. Das heißt, es gab nicht nur diesen Badge, sondern es gab auch entsprechende Empfänger, die auf dem ganzen Kongress rumhingen, also auf dem BCC damals noch in Berlin. Und das hat so mehr oder weniger gut funktioniert. Und man schaut ja dann immer ein bisschen weiter nach vorne. Die Rocket war dann eben auch schon so ein richtig programmierbares System mit Display. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was die alles noch so konnte.
Hast du das noch irgendwie auf dem Zeiger?
Das ist auf jeden Fall auch Inter-Batch-Kommunikation. Hatte die Rocket schon. Also konntest du dann irgendwie auch Games drauf spielen und wie halt so gegeneinander spielen und halt so das übliche, so dass den Farbplan dir anzeigen können. Also das, was man halt irgendwie von so einem Batch erwarten würde, wenn er irgendwie cool ist. Genau und das Radio, das ist jetzt hier dieser Apparat, das kann man ja mal für die per Video teilnehmenden Menschen vor das Glas stellen, zeigen. Relativ klobig, also das ist ja nun wirklich jenseits der Kreditkarte, das ist ja schon eher so Portemonnaie-Größe. Aber steckt auch eine Menge drin, nämlich ein SDR-System Software Defined Radio. Das heißt, hier kann man in Software im Prinzip alles steuern, was über so einen Funkkanal rein und raus geht. Sprich, das Ding ist einfach offen für alle möglichen Funkfrequenzen und damit auch über alle möglichen Protokolle, die man über diese Funkfrequenzen sprechen kann. Also es kann sowohl normales UKW-Radio sein, als auch Digitalfunk in irgendeiner Form.
Nur die passende Antenne muss man gegebenenfalls montieren.
Genau, ich glaube, es geht bei ein paar Megahertz los und bis hoch zu 6-7 Gigahertz. Also so einen riesengroßen Spektrum abgedeckt, sowohl senden als auch empfangen. Und irgendwie ist ein CPLD, also ein FPGA drauf. Das heißt, du kannst auch in nahezu Real-Time die ganzen Signale verarbeiten.
Das heißt, ich brauche nicht unbedingt irgendwie einen Rechner, um das zu verarbeiten. Der Rechner ist halt drauf. Der, der ein FPGA drauf ist, war mir tatsächlich neu.
Genau, also es ist ausreichend performant, um die Dinge ganz unabhängig von einem Computer zu machen. Und das ist, sagen wir mal, auch das Besondere daran. Abgesehen davon, dass es so in der Form, wenn man das jetzt so kaufen würde als Produkt, sicherlich deutlich teurer gewesen wäre. Also es ist natürlich auch so, dass das hier einige Sachen oder Chips gesponsert sind. Also ich glaube NXP war da jemand, der mehrere 10.000 Euro an Chipkosten gesponsert hat, was natürlich die Kosten auch reduziert hat. Nichtsdestotrotz war es immer noch sehr teuer und ein großer Teil des Eintrittspreises irgendwie geht an gegen das. Genau, aber das war halt einfach mal die Idee. Man gibt halt einfach jedem, der kommt zu einem Teil, egal ob sie jetzt unmittelbar was damit anfangen können oder nicht. Weil damit hast du natürlich eine Installed Base. Und ich denke mal, Leute, die jetzt nicht zu romantisch drauf sind und wirklich sehen, dass sie damit nichts anfangen können, werden die sicherlich auch an befreundete Nerds dann weiter erreichen, die eben wirklich auch was damit machen. Das werde ich mit meinem Gerät wahrscheinlich auch so halten. Auch wenn ich mir da jetzt noch keinen ausgesucht habe. Also einfach einen niederschwelligen Einstieg in Software Defined Values, einfach zu programmieren. Es gibt halt genug Leute, die was dafür programmieren. Es gibt irgendwie einen Git Propositor, wo irgendwie halt Leute ihren Code auschecken können, andere Leute es wieder einchecken und damit rumspielen. Das heißt, prinzipiell ist das irgendwie, also trotzdem so hohe Kosten verursacht hat, eine ziemlich gute Idee, um halt irgendwie eine große Basis an Menschen diesen Programmieren von Sachen und in dem speziellen Fall Software Defined Radio nahezubringen.
Und an der Stelle noch ein Programmhinweis zum Radio. Hat der CCC München drei Podcastsendungen produziert, die ihr auf der Seite des CCC München anhören könnt, zum Thema Radio. Da kommt das halt auch her. Genau, das wollte ich gerade drauf kommen, denn das Ganze ist eine Initiative, die glaube ich von München an stand insofern solltet ihr da, wenn ihr euch für das Thema interessiert, auf jeden Fall mal reinhören und wenn ihr noch so ein Radio braucht, dann schreibt doch mal Tim, der hat seins abzugeben.
Na ja, so schnell wird das nicht gehen.
Schade.
Es gibt ja auch den Datengarten.
Weißt du, was du anrichtest mit solchen Hinweisen?
Ja, ich weiß, aber...
Zehntausend Mails. Nein, nein, ich weiß schon, wie ich das gebe.
Schade. Also an dieser Stelle, bitte schreibt Tim keine Mails. Es war nicht... Es war nicht...
Genau, schreibt Briefe.
Ja. Damit hätten wir jetzt auch diesen Badge, der übrigens auch ein Display hat. Also es ist tatsächlich auch als Badge verwendbar.
Ich finde der Name Badge ist einfach... Badge kann man das nicht nennen. Das heißt Radio. Wenn man genau hinschaut, das finde ich ziemlich putzig eigentlich. Da ist hier oben ja auch nochmal... Ist das eigentlich auch eine Antenne oder sieht das nur aus wie eine?
Also soweit ich weiß, ist eine Antenne tatsächlich für einen Frequenzbereich integriert.
Dann ist das wahrscheinlich die, die hier wirklich so als normale Teleskopantenne auch angedeutet ist auf dieser Platine. Komm doch mal her. Ist nicht so? Endlich wagt sich mal jemand mit Kompetenz hier.
So, hallo, erstmal hallo. Tritt doch mal jemand gerade die Kopfhörer ab.
Schön, es wird auch komplett ausgestattet. Jetzt haben wir es geschafft. Jetzt haben wir so viel dummes Zeug geredet. Ist endlich mal jemand Kopfhörer.
Hallo, ich bin Valle. Und ich habe ein bisschen auf der Web schon rumgelötet. Deswegen kann ich mal zeigen, wo da die Antenne ist. Da wo die SMA-Buchse ist, drunter, findet man so ganz klein...
Was ist die SMA-Buchse?
Eine Buchse, mit der man weitere Antennen anschließen kann.
Das goldene Ding zum Drehen.
Wer das gerade anguckt, der kann das sehen.
Direkt unter dieser SMA-Buchse, die so nicht auf allen Badges drauf ist, weil man die noch anlöten muss, befindet sich im Kupfer so eine aufgewickelte Spirale.
Und weißt du welcher Frequenzbereich das ist?
Das ist für 2, 4 Gigahertz geeignet, sagten mir die Münchner. Ich habe selber nämlich auch noch nicht in Betrieb genommen. Und tatsächlich, um so eine externe Antenne anschließen zu können, muss man dann noch so eine Brücke umlöten, damit auch irgendwie das Signal dann nicht zu der internen eingebauten Antenne geht, sondern eben auf diese Buchse.
Und es gibt noch eine ganze Reihe von Erweiterungskits. Was wir sehen, da ist schon ein Gehäuse, ich glaube ein Laser geschnitten ist. Genau, das heißt, man konnte auf dem Camp auch einige Sachen dort machen und man konnte Erweiterungskits erwerben.
Genau, also zum einen mal diese Buchse. Es könnte noch eine weitere Buchse zum Sync mit anderen Badges, sagt der RF Guy, habe ich noch nicht verlötet, noch nicht ausprobiert, verbaut werden unten rechts. Und zusätzlich, um Abstreuung zu verhindern, hier zwei Radio Cages über die empfindliche Elektronik. Und zusätzlich noch für mehr Blink ein paar LEDs.
Da gab es noch mal einen separaten Satz LEDs zum Anlöten. Die habe ich auch irgendwie bestellt. Aber vor dem Anlöten kommt glaube ich erst mal die generelle Inbetriebnahme. Wie war das? Fertigstellung vor?
Inbetriebnahme vor Fertigstellung.
Ah ja, genau. Inbetriebnahme vor Fertigstellung. Genau, und das ist wahrscheinlich bei dem...
Boot hier sogar richtig.
Es muss es aber wenigstens für die Leute, die zugucken in die Kamera, so mit mehr Blink. Also was wir hier sehen, das muss man vielleicht mal beschreiben, ist, wir sehen jede Menge LEDs und einen mini kleinen vergleichsweise LCD-Screen, die man wahrscheinlich unter diesen gepimpten LEDs gar nicht mehr richtig lesen kann.
Nee, da wurde man auf dem Camp auch manchmal so angesprochen, mach das doch mal aus, weil wenn man da so um zwei nachts mit so hellen LEDs in der Gegend rumrennt, ist es ein bisschen anstrengend.
Ja, also gerade als Batch nachts würde ich das nicht unbedingt die ganzen Leute herum aufnehmen wollen. Aber auch das ist relativ gefahrlos, weil die meisten Leute das wahrscheinlich alles erst hinterher machen.
Mit ein paar Leuten habe ich geredet und einer hat dann auch was geschrieben, was irgendwie die LEDs auf 20% Helligkeit laufen lässt.
Und was würdest du meinen, was ist jetzt so die Killer App für das Teil?
Also das erste, was ich gedacht habe, dass man vielleicht hätte gebrauchen können, wenn mein Beifahrer das so gemacht hätte, wie andere Beifahrer das gemacht haben, wäre ein FM-Transmitter fürs Radio, wie Heimfahrt. Ja, als Fahrer kann ich doch jetzt nicht. Ja, ich bin gefahren und mein Beifahrer hat sich da jetzt nicht engagiert, aber andere Beifahrer haben das.
Ihr habt dann sozusagen den Lötkolben direkt installiert im Auto?
Nee, aber wenn man das schon auf dem Camp fertiggestellt hat, dann kann man ja vielleicht auf dem Rückweg schon ein bisschen ein eigenes Radio hören.
Ist da eine Klinkenbuchse dran eigentlich?
Ja, aber frag mich nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Aber FM-Transmitter im Sinne von spielt Files ab?
Ja, man kann da relativ fertige Patches anscheinend für GNU Radio direkt anschließen und dann die Funkwellen mit dem Computer bespielen.
Ist das wirklich die Killer App für die Heimfahrt?
Das ist die Killer App für die Heimfahrt und mehr habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen.
Hast du was im Sinn oder hast du was gehört, was Leute so meinten, dass es so sein müsste?
2, 4 Gigahertz ist ja sicherlich erstmal ein interessantes Spektrum. Dann ist da noch was drauf, glaube ich, um die Kommunikation von Flugzeugen mitzuhören. Also einfach nur so Positionierungen.
Es gibt ja diverse Sachen, die auf Funk funktionieren, sei es Alarmanlagen oder Kommunikations-Zwischenzügen oder was auch immer. Das kann man tatsächlich alles damit machen. Das ist halt wirklich universal, zum Mobil vor allem auch. Das heißt, immer wenn du draußen unterwegs bist und denkst, da ist so eine Antenne und ich würde jetzt mal gerne wissen, was die tut, dann schaltest du das Gerät an und guckst mal, wie was darüber geht.
Und das Spannende ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, noch abschließend, das Ganze ist kompatibel zum HackRF-Projekt, das ist auch so eine Platine. Und die Software ist, soweit ich weiß, kompatibel. Was bedeutet, man kann da schon auf relativ viel Community-Arbeit zurückgreifen. Genau, und dann dieser Badge nochmal als ganz spannende Sache, was wir glaube ich noch vergessen haben. And now for something completely different. Engel, freiwillige Arbeit. Wir haben immer gesagt, wer da im Vorfeld an der Orga aktiv ist. Aber letztendlich sind das ja die Leute, die zwar die Verantwortung haben, aber die ganzen kleinen Arbeiten, die ganzen kleinen Details machen ja letztendlich nochmal ganz andere Leute. Erzähl doch mal, wer ist so ein Engel, wer macht das und warum sollte man das machen?
Also ich glaube, Engel gibt es schon seit es den Kongress gibt, oder zumindest nach den ersten paar Kongress gab es Engel. Das sind halt die Leute, die helfen, den Kongress oder das Camp überhaupt erst durchzuführen. Also seit es angefangen von die Klosse sauber machen oder an den Vortragsseelen Eingangskontrolle, also dass die Sitze irgendwie ordentlich belegt sind. Oder die Heralde, die die Vorträge ankündigen, die die Speaker einweisen.
Gucken, dass die Wege frei bleiben.
Also wirklich alle Aufgaben im Kongress werden von Engeln gemacht. Und ich glaube auch jeder, zumindest jeden, den ich kenne, der schon eine Weile dabei ist, hat irgendwann mal früher als Engel angefangen. Bei mir war es der 13C3, glaube ich. Und dann saß ich auch in die Nachtschicht an der Kasse und habe halt komische Videos geguckt, während ich noch nichts zu tun hatte. Das gehört halt einfach dazu. Wenn man in diesem Club irgendwann mal reinrutscht zum Kongress, dann macht man einfach Engel.
Man kommt da auch rein zu kommen, nehme ich.
Du hast halt irgendwie eine gute, wenn du halt keine Leute kennst, dann ist das erstmal natürlich eine gute Gelegenheit, Leute kennenzulernen, die halt alle auch ähnliche Interessen haben. Das heißt, dann hast du halt irgendwie was zu tun auch, hast Leute, mit denen du was tun kannst, unterstützt das Event selber und ist halt einfach so, wie es halt laufen sollte. Und vor allem, man lernt halt auch einfach den Event als solchen kennen. Man lernt die Organisation dieser Veranstaltung kennen. Das Beste, was man eigentlich machen kann, ist, es gibt so Spezialisten, die graben sich mal irgendwo so ein in so einem Bereich und dann bleiben sie auch irgendwie dabei, weil das ihr Ding ist. Genauso gibt es aber so Hopper, die eigentlich sich sagen, jeden Kongress mach ich in einem anderen Bereich, um einfach mal so in vier, fünf Jahren vielleicht nicht alles, aber zumindest sehr viel Unterschiedliches gesehen zu haben.
Also quasi mal so ein Camp oder so ein Kongress durchzuspielen.
Genau, und alles kann sehr interessant sein, auch wenn das jetzt so, was weiß ich, Eingänge bewachen und so, das klingt natürlich jetzt erstmal langweilig, ist auch vielleicht teilweise langweilig. Auf der anderen Seite hat man auch so ein bisschen Leerlauf und kann die Veranstaltung auch auf einer ganz anderen Perspektive sehen. Du siehst so viele Leute an dir vorbeigehen, du kriegst einen ganz anderen Blick auf diese Veranstaltung. Wenn du in NOC oder VOC oder sowas, also in diese elementaren Infrastrukturen reingehst, dann kriegst du auf einmal das Vortragsprogramm in so einer Megadichte mit. Du siehst halt auch überhaupt mal, was während der Veranstaltung netzwerkmäßig da so geht, was da so für Probleme entstehen, was da für wilde Aktionen getrieben werden, sonstige Attacken reinkommen, abgewehrt werden müssen. Was für Probleme einfach entstehen. Und das ist auch ein super Praktikum. Also ich denke mal, man kann in so 3-4 Tagen Kongress oder Camp mehr lernen als wahrscheinlich in so einer kompletten IT-Ausbildung. Das ist vielleicht etwas überzogen, aber man lernt einfach Dinge kennen, die man vor allem so auch in der Form nirgends wo sonst antrifft. Also allein diese Netzwerkinfrastruktur, oder sagen wir mal die Technologieinfrastruktur des Kongresses und des Camps, das gibt es nicht, das kann man nicht kaufen. Das sind dann auch wirklich so ganz Vorreiterrollen. Ich weiß noch, auf dem ersten Camp, da waren wir dann halt WLAN. Das gab es halt noch nirgendwo, aber wir haben wieder angefangen, die ersten Exis-Prints aufzubauen und die ersten PCMCAE-WLAN-Karten zu verteilen und das einfach mal auszurühren, wie das funktioniert. Das war halt Jahre, bevor das auch sinnvoll irgendwo eingesetzt wurde.
Und nochmal, um auf das zurückzukommen, hast du gesagt, man sitzt irgendwie am Eingang und wartet im Prinzip, weil man eine Nachtschicht hat. Also ich hab da schon genug Anekdoten gehört, dass da Freundschaften entstanden sind.
Auf jeden Fall. Lustige Sachen passieren auch einfach. Verrücktes Zeug. Gerade nachts drehen die dann immer so richtig durch und irgendwelche verspulten Aktionen finden statt, die man sonst nie mitbekommen hätte.
Und wer irgendwie seine Profession da einbringen will, ich glaube zum Beispiel im Zert bringen sich auch ziemlich viele Leute ein, die einfach so Sunny-Rettungsgeschichten auch in ihrem echten Leben machen.
Das ist ja eh nochmal so ein spezielles Phänomen. Ich glaube, wir sind auch der einzige Computer Club auf diesem Planeten, der sein eigenes Medical Team am Start hat.
Wir reden da durchaus nicht nur von Leuten, die das hobbymäßig machen, sondern die wirklich im echten Leben Ärzte, Sanitäter sind, Rettungsfahrer.
Das ist das schöne Beispiel von dem in den Hafen gefallenen iPhone. Der ist halt in den Hafen gefallen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das T-Shirt davon erfahren hat.
Auf jeden Fall meinten sie, wir haben auch noch Rettungstaucher dabei. Dann holen wir doch mal unseren Schnorchel und unsere Taucherbrille und springen mal rein.
Sie haben tatsächlich das iPhone rausgeholt.
Sie haben es auseinandergenommen, sie haben es gesäubert und es funktionierte danach noch. Das musst du erstmal bringen. Ah ja, Rettungstaucher haben. Ich meine, die haben nicht so viel zu tun. Das ist lustig, als dieser Regeneinsatz so direkt vor unserem Zelt so ein Wagen DLRG im Wasserrettung vorholt.
Ich dachte mir, so schlimm ist das schon?
Ich habe auch eine unglaublich große Anzahl von Leuten, die halt, also gerade bei diesem Camp war es nochmal viel mehr als sonst. Also sonst haben wir immer so 10%, 15% von Teilnehmern, die sich tatsächlich aktiv als Engel einbringen. Und diesmal waren es, glaube ich, 25-25% oder so, die wirklich gesagt haben, wir sind hier und wir sind gerne bereit in ein paar Stunden. Es war richtig, richtig viel. Sie kriegen dafür halt irgendwie, also sie kriegen halt was zu essen, aber irgendwie das... Und ein T-Shirt. Aber was die Leute teilweise aufopfern, also halt wirklich Stunden, Tage lang irgendwie Aufgaben machen, die man normalerweise nicht machen wollen würde. Und einfach dazu beitragen, dass sich das Camp funktioniert. Man kann das gar nicht hoch genug loben, diese Einsatzbereitschaft, weil ohne die Leute würde das halt einfach überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren. Es ist illusorisch zu denken, man könnte ein Camp ohne Engel machen. Das geht einfach nicht. Oder ein Kongress.
Also mit diesem Lobhymne an die Engel, wo wir euch auch bitten möchten. Also hallo hier.
Send me an Engel, ihr wart ganz toll.
Bitte einmal Applaus für die Engel.
Und nach allen anderen, die ihre Gesundheit ruiniert haben auf dieser Veranstaltung.
Gab es eigentlich nennenswert Kongress solche?
Ich kenn einige, die irgendwie krank geworden sind, aber auf jeden Fall nicht in der Größenordnung.
Wir hatten schon einiges. Wir hatten abgerissene Zähnegel, Muskelzerrungen, böses Saar.
Das Schöne, was wir von Zert hatten, die haben jeden Tag eine Statistik herausgebracht, welche Verletzungen, wie die...
Linker Fuß, rechter Fuß.
Genau, dann war es an einem Tag der linke Fuß, die Zeltherringe und am nächsten Mal Sonnenbrände und Schnittverletzungen. Die nehmen das alles zwar ernst, aber auch mit einem gewissen Spaßfaktor dabei.
und von euch möchte ich abschließend wissen, wie schwer war es für euch in der Realität wieder anzukommen? Also ich kann das nur für mich sagen, für mich war das tatsächlich nach dem Camp deutlich schwieriger nochmal als nach jeglichem Kongress irgendwie wieder in dieses normale Leben zurückzukommen.
Also ich hab's richtig gemacht, diesmal ich bin erstens bis Donnerstag geblieben, also noch eins, zwei, drei Tage nach dem offiziellen Ende und bin dann nochmal ein Wochenende an See gefahren. Dann ging's so. Ja, also bei mir war es diesmal auch erstaunlich, also sonst hab ich irgendwie nach so Kongressen und Camps auch immer so diese, ich nenne es immer so schön, die Post-Event-Depression, wo dann einfach, also ich meine du bist halt einfach über fünf, sechs, sieben Tage mit irgendwie tausenden von Leuten auf dem Acker, irgendwie hast du die ganze Zeit irgendwie Action und dann bist du plötzlich alleine zu Hause und diesmal irgendwie auch so bis Donnerstag irgendwie noch da geblieben und dann hatte ich mich noch besucht. Das heißt, diesmal erstaunlich gut vonstatten gegangen.
Und da gerne bei dir?
Ich hatte noch ein ganz, ganz schräges Anschluss-Event. Ich war mit meiner Mutti noch auf einem Konzert von einem italienischen Schlagersänger.
Ich glaube, das gibt dann die nötigen Übergänge.
Ganz genau. Danach hatten wir dann noch einen Tag im Spa und Montag war dann wieder Eingewinnungsphase, schön im Büro.
Man kann es entweder ganz langsam ausklingen lassen oder den richtigen Hammer.
Auch Spender noch richtig hart. Wir sollten noch eine E-Mail-Adresse durchsagen. Eine wichtige E-Mail-Adresse.
Dann sag sie durch.
Die wichtigste E-Mail-Adresse aller Zeiten.
Na ja, für die, die was verloren vergessen haben und die Hoffnung, dass es irgendwo auftaucht, besteht weiterhin. Ich hoffe, ich sag das jetzt richtig. Der Kollege, der das gerne wollte, hört mich aber nicht. Okay, ich glaube, es war Camp2015-lostandfound at cccv.de.
Klingt auf jeden Fall gut.
In jedem Fall werden wir das auch in den Shownoten nochmal verlinken, da nicken die Shownoten schon. Ja, ansonsten danke ich euch. Schön, dass ihr da wart. Und das war's schon wieder. Chaosradio 215.
Beiden. Während des Camps oder zur Vorbereitung hat man immer so, ist so viel Stress und sobald es vorbei ist, dann ist es eigentlich vorbei. Eigentlich will man es jetzt sofort wieder machen, nächstes Jahr sofort oder in zwei Monaten wieder.
Aber erst mal kommt der Kongress?
Ja, nach dem Kongress denkt man auch erst mal nicht wirklich über das nächste Camp.
Nach dem Kongress ist vor dem Kongress.
So, mit diesen Worten lassen wir euch mal wirklich alleine. Macht's gut und auf Wiedersehen.